[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you very much for the
hospitality I certainly want to add my
welcome to dr. Dunn lamps but before I
start I always like to have a couple of
little surveys here so I know who I'm
talking to
I start out how many of you are here
because you're her trade eyo program
isn't amazing how many of you are here
because a friend invited you to come
that's great how many of you are here
because you thought this is a tax
protest meeting yet more than two people
together in America that's a tax protest
meeting one last piece how many of you
grew up in a farm or still having
anything to do with livestock raise your
hand okay great fifty percent well we're
gonna get along fine we'll bring
everybody else along with us myself I
grew up on a farm of beef farm in
Missouri about 80 miles west of st.
Louis and like everybody else that
raises livestock we raise a lot of our
own feed corn and soybeans and hay and
we grind this up into a flower and we do
add vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals to this we would make pellets
or cake out of it and feed those calves
for about six to nine months before we
ship them off to be butchered say back
the very best ones for own family of
course and the thing that fascinated me
as a teenager was the fact that we ate
out of those very same fields we had a
garden at the end of the field we
grouped peas and beans and squash and
peppers and whatnot we also saved back
five rows of corn for the family we
wanted to live to be a hundred with no
aches and pains and we didn't do the
same thing for ourselves we did for
those cows and as a teenager this is
very fascinating for me I always used to
ask my dad I'd say hey pops
how come we go to all that trouble for
those calves we grind up their feet add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
and feed them for six nine months and
knock them in the head need them and we
have those very same fields don't do
that for ourselves of course being a
Missouri farmer he'd give me a lot of
Missouri farm wisdom he'd say things
like shut up boy
forgetting farm-fresh food fresh air
free exercise don't ask complicated
questions so I was glad when I got rid
of that farm exercise and went to the
University of Missouri and got into AG
school a major was an animal husbandry
in nutrition my minor was some field
crops and soils but I really didn't get
an answer to my basic question until I
became a freshman veterinary student at
the University of Missouri and as a
freshman veterinary student what I
learned was the reason we put vitamins
and minerals and trace minerals into
animal feeds is because we don't have
insurance for them
we don't have BlueCross BlueShield major
medical hospitalization we don't have
Medicare Medicaid or at Hillery to watch
out for them
[Applause]
and as a result if we were to use a
human healthcare type of system for
livestock could be a real sticker shock
for most people because of the
veterinary care the hamburger would cost
two hundred and seventy five dollars a
pound and boneless skinless chicken
breasts would be four hundred and fifty
dollars a pound so to keep things on an
even keel where everybody could get at
this meat we learned that we could
prevent and cure diseases with nutrition
after graduating vet school I got
diverted for a couple of years and went
to Africa and worked with Marlin Perkins
from the old Mutual of Omaha Wild
Kingdom the days and that was a lot of
fun you know people always ask you when
you're a veterinarian they're you a
large animal vet or animal vet allows an
extra large animal vet because I worked
with elephants and rhinos and things
like that for a couple years got to be
frank buck used a tranquilizer gun and
got to move animals all across Africa
and to Europe and United States in fact
many of the African elephants and rhinos
that you see in wild animal parks and
zoos are ones that either caught our
offsprings of one that I caught after
two years of doing that Marlin sent me a
telegram and invited me back to the
states to work on a big project the
National Institutes of Health had given
him seven and a half million dollars to
study pollution in the mid 60s this is
when we first recognized that there was
pollution in our air in our water and
our food and nobody quite knew what that
meant over a long period of time and so
we had many many projects going on in
the mid sixties but one of them the one
that I was working on was one word I had
to do autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States and I was to look for
a species of animals who was ultra
sensitive to pollution and we were going
to use that species of animals much like
the old coal miners used to use a canary
you know they take the canary down to
mine and the canary would act as an
early warning system if methane gas or
carbon monoxide would leak out into the
mine the canary would drop off the perch
and died long before the men were in
danger we're gonna take these animals
and put them in little strategic spots
all around the world
and pay attention to them and if they
started dying we knew we were in danger
we'll make a long story short after some
12 years working at the st. Louis Zoo in
the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago the Bronx
in New York the Nationals in DC the LA
Zoo and many other big ones throughout
the United States had done some 17,500
autopsies and over four hundred and
fifty four species of animals plus three
thousand human beings who lived in close
proximity to the zoos for a comparison
and what I learned was pretty
frightening every one of those animals
and every one of the people who died of
natural causes died of a nutritional
deficiency disease and that got me very
excited and I wrote as dr. Dunlap said I
wrote 75 scientific papers eight text
books about that big you have to pay a
hundred and forty dollars for those tech
books I'm not sure that the medical
students ever read them but they had to
buy them to pass the course one of those
kind of things so I was on 20/20 with
Hugh Downs and Geraldo before he got his
nose broken was on every network TV I
back then was only three networks 1,700
newspapers lectured all across the
United States back in the late sixties
and early seventies just like I'm doing
now and I couldn't get anybody excited
about those findings because we could
just put men on the moon we had a
high-tech cold war going on with the
Soviets and we had just committed twenty
three billion dollars with a B twenty
three billion dollars which is a lot of
money back then to finding cures and
vaccines for cancer and so talking about
nutritional deficiency diseases 30 35
years ago in America was pretty low on
everybody's totem pole but I knew it was
important so I got frustrated enough I
went back to school for four years up in
Portland Oregon became a physician and I
practiced for 12 years in the general
family practice took care of chainsaw
wounds delivered babies looked at
hemorrhoids you know all the fun things
of life and I was always very honest
with my patients I always put my
veterinary degree on the wall along with
the medical degree
and for some new patients for some
reason they'd always focus in on that
veterinary degree and they say doc I'm
here for a physical mine the right place
looks like a vet's office and if I saw
that they were from the farm I always
kept one of these full-length obstetric
Oh gloves I used for AI and examining
mirrors and cows you know I put that on
and they'd backstroke out of the office
- they knew they knew what that was far
and the nurses have to chase him down
say doc don't terrorize the patient's
like that but the most fun I had of
course was using everything I'd learned
in veterinary nutrition of my human
patients and was no great surprise to me
that it just worked like a charm and
what I'm gonna do tonight is share with
you a lot of what I learned and if you
take home just 10% of what I share with
you you're gonna save yourself an
enormous amount of unnecessary misery
you're gonna save yourselves a gob of
money and you're gonna add many many
healthful years to your life there's no
extra charge if you want to take home 50
percent or a hundred percent but I'll
feel good and sleep well tonight if you
just take home ten percent well let's
get started and to do that I'm going to
tell you that the human being has the
genetic capacity the the capability of
living healthily to be 120 to 140 and
I'm going to prove that to you in a
second there's no doubt about it
unfortunately Americans don't do a very
good job when it comes to this and when
the World Health Organization kind of
looked at the top 32 industrialized
nations on earth and said how long do
these people live who lives as long as
we ranked 17th in longevity there's
actually 16 other countries whose people
who live longer than we did
these are industrialized nations now
then we ranked 19th in healthfulness
that means there was 18 other countries
whose peoples live longer than we do
before they develop diabetes heart
disease arthritis osteoporosis and so
forth we ranked 23rd in live births and
first year survivability of our babies
and we ranked dead last thirty second
out of 32 when it came to preventing
birth defects all these statistics
really mean is that we have the most
expensive health care system in the
world but not the best and that's why
many of you are here tonight because
you're seeking some information well
there's no less than six cultures on
earth whose peoples routinely live to be
120 to 140 and I'm just going to give
you a very brief description there's two
places that you can actually pick up a
lot of details number one is the January
1973 issue of National Geographic and if
you don't have the National Geographic
stacked up in your garage like I do
go to any library and pick him up again
that's January 1973 they did a special
issue on these cultures who live to be
over 120 to 140 and then my wife and I
wrote a book in November of 1994 about
eight months ago now and that book in
Chapter age is called the age beaters
not the egg beaters the age beaters and
that goes into a Norma's amount of
detail of what these people do
culturally in diet-wise and so forth to
live healthfully to 120 to 140 now just
very briefly these cultures include the
mountain tribes of Tibetans and these
people were made famous in 1933 at the
death of a fellow by the name of Woolley
and he was born in 1677 if you're quick
with numbers you'll notice that he died
at age 256 and when he was a hundred and
six the Chinese imperial government
began publishing his birth dates and
birthday parties every year for a
hundred and fifty years when he died his
obituary was in every newspaper in the
world because he'd been tracked for many
many years and everybody knew him and a
year after he died a Pulitzer
prize-winning book was published for
which his life was the inspiration for
this book was called Lost Horizon and
many of you will recall that story in
that book that talked about the valley
of shangri-la where people could live to
be over 200 if they'd let a good
Christian life and and in fact it was a
humble agrarian farmed and gardened and
they shun the evil and the violence of
the outside world they could live to be
over 200 and so if you haven't read that
book I'd urge you to do it and then
about three years later they made it
into a black and white movie again his
life was the inspiration for that movie
and if you have access to a Blockbuster
video store you can actually rent that
original movie Lost Horizon then what is
now eastern Pakistan
the Hun's Azhar legendary for living
healthfully to be over 120 and if you've
hung around health food stores and read
alternative health literature and
nutrition literature for years you run
into the name of the Huns
they've been held up as being very
helpful along with people for over 50
years and then during the 1970s Dannon
yogurt made the russian-georgian stain
as some of you remember that ad prior to
this ad nobody could spell yogurt in
America and afterwards of course
everybody wanted it now this is where a
hundred and forty year old guy from
russia and georgia wore a uniform from
the crimea war war that took place 120
years previous had all those medals held
up a big saber in one hand and had a cup
of dan and yogurt in the other hand
smiled a lot and waved it around you're
supposed to believe that it was Dan and
yogurt that made him live to be a
hundred and forty he's very impressive
and because he had his son standing next
to him who was 120 and his grandson who
was a hundred and his great grandson who
was 80 and so forth so it's very
believable and then after the breakup of
the Soviet Union a few years ago we
began learning about other cultures in
that same mountain range that caucasus
mountains the Azerbaijanis Abkhazians
turkish Tani's and the russians studied
all of these people for some seventy
years and literally wrote thousands of
scientific papers on their physical
exams and their diets and blood tests
and hair analysis trying to figure out
what it was that made these people
special because there were different
races different religions but they had
the common denominator of health and
longevity then in the Western Hemisphere
we actually have two peoples that are
famous for longevity both are in the
Andes Mountains the vilcabamba Indians
and Andes Mountains of Ecuador and in
southeastern Peru just east of the
Peruvian city the Aztec city of Machu
Picchu the Titicaca I just like them
because it's a fun name the Titicaca is
I mean
an old Halperin can you say that and get
away with
now remember I'm from Missouri and we're
a bunch of hard-hit a dutchman there in
Missouri and it's so noticeable and
everybody knows us on our license plate
that says we're the show-me-state I mean
we believe nothing of what we hear and
only half of what we see and so it's
pretty hard to pull the wool over our
eyes and of course we have a bunch of
farm sayings there like I know you do
here one of my favorites as the proof is
in the pudding that means you can tell
me you're a good cook but until I taste
your cooking I'm not going to believe
you and one of my hobbies I have several
hobbies but one of my hobbies is
collecting theories on health and
longevity and over the years I've taken
these theories and examined them to see
if the proof is in the pudding was there
any reality to these things was there
anything to support these claims that
these theories work so I'm going to show
you a few of them and let's have a look
one of the more popular ones now is the
Paleolithic diet and lifestyle this is
where you're supposed to live like a
caveman and of course so you can't eat
corn fed beef from Iowa you have to
chase down low-fat antelope by foot you
can't use an ATV or a rifle or a bow and
arrow you have to choke them to death
with your bare hands
you're supposed to eat everything raw
right and live like a caveman if you
don't sweat in your Labor's you're
supposed to join a health club and sweat
three times a week and that's the
caveman or the Paleolithic lifestyle
let's have a look and see if the proof
is in the pudding
the only real hard evidence we have is
this fellow here Oh
Otzi and he was made famous because his
mummified corpse was found in the odds
Val Valley of Italy when a glacier began
to melt and recede and when they found
his corpse all the tools and weapons he
had with him were pure copper so they
knew he was from the Copper Age
somewhere between four and six thousand
years ago and they did carbon dating of
his tissues they found that he actually
died 5300 years ago and through
examinations of his body they figured he
died in the prime of life somewhere
between 25 and 40 years of age and they
did a series of x-rays on him to see if
he had any of the diseases that plague
modern man and what they found was very
surprising number one they found out
that he had severe degenerative
arthritis to the cervical vertebra of
his neck the lumbar vertebrae of his
lower back in both hips and even more
surprising he had severe advanced
calcification and arteriosclerosis of
his coronary arteries in his heart the
aorta pulmonary artery coming out of his
heart and the large iliac arteries going
down into his lace so the proof isn't in
the pudding and I guarantee you he
didn't eat three eggs every morning for
breakfast and certainly didn't need any
Big Macs or hamburgers or anything like
that or corn-fed beef so the proof is
not in the pudding for the Paleolithic
lifestyle or diet then there's the
lifestyle here very this is where you're
supposed to get injections of extracts
of placenta of sheep or cattle or
embryonic tissues you're supposed to get
the DNA and the RNA and this is supposed
to rejuvenate and you're supposed to get
20 years or 50 years younger and live to
be over a hundred and let's have a look
and see if the proof is in the pudding
for that now dr. Peter Stefan here was a
homeopathic physician this is from 1994
and he
had a clinic in London he went all
around Europe lectured and told people
about his elixir of youth and please
come to his clinic in London and he
would give you these injections and of
course if he took his own stuff the
proof isn't on the pudding for the live
cell therapy because he died at age 50
from a cardiomyopathy heart attack which
is in fact a simple selenium deficiency
let me ask you real quick how many of
you know what stiff lamb disease or
white muscle diseases raise your hand
okay sure all the farmers who deal with
livestock and what what causes that what
do you know causes it a deficiency of
selenium deficiency of selenium you bet
okay then is it amazing how farmers know
these things and doctors don't another
one of these theories has gotten real
popular lately since Deepak Chopra wrote
something like four best-selling books
on the body life spirit thing body mind
spirit this is where you're supposed to
meditate a lot and do yoga and eat vague
an or vegetarian diets and just growing
up on the farm I just knew as a boy that
that wasn't gonna work out because back
when I was a kid
two things didn't work out let alone
body-mind-spirit I remember we used to
entertain ourselves you know by patting
our head and rub it on her stomach and
all somebody had to do is make a face
and you get derailed and so thinking
about living to be over a hundred with a
body mind spirit thing didn't sound
right and certainly the proof is not in
the pudding for that
Rita Guerra who was the premier
meditation and yoga instructor in the
Western Hemisphere and director of the
Himalayan Institute was a vague and
didn't supplement with any vitamins or
minerals and didn't eat any animal
products died at age 55 McCarty mapa the
heart attack a simple selenium
deficiency disease even though she was
spiritually elevated
I think you get the picture now the one
that the physicians are really into now
the ones that are really into it is the
Mediterranean diet they love this
Mediterranean diet thing this is very
supposed to give up red meat and you're
supposed to rip the chicken skin off
your chicken and eat a lot of fish and
you're supposed to eat lots of
vegetables and grains lots of pasta you
know and breads and things little wines
okay according to the Mediterranean diet
but the proof is not in the pudding for
the Mediterranean diet first of all
because the average lifespan for the
Greeks and the Italians who eat the most
of it is seventy five point five just
like us
there was no longevity benefit for that
diet and here's a specific example Pope
John Paul the second of course has been
in Italy for the last 15 or so years he
just turned 75 years old about four
years ago but not four or four weeks ago
excuse me four weeks ago and he has
degenerative arthritis he has
osteoporosis deficient to the point
where he had to have hip replacement
surgery his failing health doesn't have
stammen anymore where he has to cancel
fifty percent of his speaking
engagements and I mean you would like to
think that if anybody in Italy would get
the very best that the Mediterranean
diet could offer would be the Pope right
and unless he's been sneaking sausage in
from Poland under the table and eating
that all the time the proof is not in
the pudding for the Mediterranean diet
now one of my heroes in the alternative
health field for many many years of
course was Linus Pauling and lioness was
famous for a variety of things number
one he was one of two people who ever
had two Nobel Prizes I mean this guy was
a genius
when it came to biochemistry and biology
and zoology nobody could argue with his
intelligence and certainly he was
probably one of the more intelligent
human beings in our century and maybe
ever the other thing he was famous for
was his interest in vitamin C and he
believed that you could get everything
you needed from your four food groups
you get all the vitamins and minerals
and amino acids and fatty acids you
needed from your four food groups
however because of the stresses of
modern day life and the pollution in the
air and water and food he believes you
needed extra vitamin C and to prove that
that would help you live a long healthy
he faithfully took 10,000 milligrams of
vitamin C every day for 35 years didn't
take any other supplements but he took
10,000 milligrams of vitamin C every day
for 35 years and of course he died at
age 93 from a widely disseminated
prostate cancer and here's after I've
read all his books and papers and
scientific literature and so forth and
listened to his tapes and looked at his
videos and whatnot and reading things on
vitamin C myself here's what I can
guarantee you if you faithfully take
10,000 milligrams of vitamin C every day
for 35 years and you're a woman
I can guarantee you you will never get
prostate cancer
now how old can you live to be in
America and according to the Guinness
World Book of Records this little gal
here Margaret ski actually died at age
115 in 1994 a year ago and she looks
pretty good for 115 doesn't she looks a
lot better than these 25 year olds who
subsist on Pepsi's and ding-dongs and
things like that
and she's very bright didn't have
Alzheimer's and she died of a
nutritional deficiency disease she
actually fell and broke her hip from
osteoporosis three weeks later she was
dead as she died of pneumonia this is
not unusual because 75% of the people
over age 65 in America who break a hip
or a major leg bone don't live 90 days
they die have complications of that
fracture a vogue abour just last week
died at age 74 fractured her hip went
into the hospital five days later she
was dead from pneumonia it doesn't
matter how much money you have if you
have a calcium deficiency it's going to
get you okay this little gal here is
very interesting her name is Jeanne
Calment from France turned 120 February
21st of this year 1995 and the thing
that I found interesting of course she
was much sharper than her doctors and
they were only able to get her to quit
smoking after they put her in a nursing
home at age 120
they were afraid that it was going to
shorten her life
and what a great lady and there's no
reason why she can't live to be 140
because she doesn't have cancer
heart disease or high blood pressure
diabetes in this little gal here Suzie
Brunson according to her family died at
age 123 in December of 1994 and this was
this claim was based on the fact that
her birth date December 25th 1870 was
recorded in the family Bible and I
assume that she died of a natural cause
because they didn't say that she died of
an overdose or recreational drugs or
drive-by shooting or anything like that
this fellow here Bauer
chief of the third world country of
Niger died at age 126 and one of his
wives was eulogizing him at his funeral
and said that he still was in possession
of all his own teeth when he died at age
126 which means he didn't have any
osteoporosis number one and I think she
was bragging on him you know kind of in
the backdoor that perhaps other parts of
his Anatomy still function too at the
age 100 26 his fellow here from another
third world country of Syria died at age
133 and of course he was in the Guinness
World Book of Records not because he was
133 many people live longer than that as
you will see and he remarried at the age
of 84 the fourth time that didn't get
him in the Guinness World Book of
Records I have to do is go to Vegas and
sit a little chapel as you see that but
the fact that he fathered four boys and
five girls were the same wife after the
age of 80 you know 9 months for the
pregnancy and then breastfeeding and a
little time in between his baby he was
still fathering children after the age
of a hundred that's what got him into
the Guinness World Book of Records so
there's hope for some of you guys in the
back of the room
now this little gal here from Iran
according to them a January 1995 died at
age 161 she's getting close to Hunza the
village that she lived and was very
close to the honza's in died at age 161
and the interesting thing about her
obituary is she was survived by six
living children who ranged in age
between 120 and 128 they hadn't even
left home to go to college yet
and then another thing I found
interesting was her oldest son said his
mother had never visited a doctor never
took any pharmaceuticals or drugs did
take a few herbs during her life and so
there's a beginning to be a message
develop here right now these are a
couple of birthday announcements not
obituaries this fellow here chali MS Mel
off from Azerbaijan the Caucasus
Mountains in Western Soviet Union at
this time May of 1973 turned 168 and he
was featured in that 1973 January 1973
issue of the National Geographic and
when he turned 168 some five months
later he went out and hoed the garden to
show reporters how vigorous he was 168
then two years later another Russian
majeeda guy ever turned 140 he was also
from Azerbaijan and the literal
translation of his villages name was a
village of centenarians people who live
to be a hundred and fifty percent of the
people in his village at his birthdate
were over a hundred lastly on this
longevity thing in 1993 there were eight
scientists who lived in this big dome
biosphere 2 in Arizona for two years and
when they came out in November of 1993
these people had lived in this dome for
two years and they recycled everything
lived in a pollution free environment
they ate moderate calorie levels every
day took in large doses of vitamins and
minerals and when they came out they had
physical exams performed on them by
doctors from the UCLA Medical School
University of California Los Angeles and
they took all this data from the
physical exams blood tests hair analysis
put the information into the medical
computers and the medical computers
projected that they could live to be 165
based on all this data if they continued
to do outside the dome what they had
done inside the dome there's no doubt
that human beings have the genetic
capacity lived to be one
28 140 and some extraordinary
individuals are gonna live to be 150 and
160 but there's no reason why the
average age in America shouldn't be a
hundred instead of seventy five point
five now over the years I have literally
reviewed and revved and examined over a
thousand pieces of literature on health
and longevity and no matter who writes
it or withers from Russia or Europe or
the United States at a veterinary
literature on the subject of health and
longevity there's two basic themes that
come out and I call them concept number
one concept number two that's what we're
gonna cover now concept number one for
health and longevity is I call it how to
avoid stepping on the landmines it's
very simple things you don't want to do
that way you can survive long enough for
the other thing to kick in concept
number two to kick in concept number one
you don't want to smoke you don't want
to abuse alcohol you don't want to do
drugs you don't want a jog down the
highway of two o'clock in the morning
wearing an all-black ninja suit you're
gonna get hit by a car right there's
nothing greater than a mirror from a
truck then you don't want to jump out of
a hot air balloon from two hundred and
fifty foot up with a 300-foot bungee
cord on
as crazy as that sounds millions of
Americans throw away their healthy
physical bodies every year doing all
these stupid things so I take just a few
seconds to remind you of that
lastly in concept normal concept number
one if at all possible you want to avoid
going to a doctor because given half a
chance a doctor will kill you
[Applause]
now to some of you that may seem a
little flippant right to gosh this guy's
really weird and so I'm gonna back that
up with a little bit of a statistic here
so you know that I'm coming from the
area of truth January of 1973 Ralph
Nader came out with the results of a
3-year study on deaths and American
hospitals and was very shocking what he
came up where they said and this is a
quote from his study quote 300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote 300,000 now that's
each year now that can just to have a
comparison to understand how big a
figure that is let's compare that figure
300,000 a year with it's killed by the
medical profession he used the word
killed let's compare with ten years of
military losses in Vietnam where we had
56,000 killed over 10 years by enemies
that had artillery and explosives and
bayonets and rifles trying to kill you
and averaged out 5,600 a year and for
that we had millions of people protest
they poured out into the streets
we had political anarchy the last three
years of that ten-year war we chased a
president out of the presidency we
actually shot students in Kent State
Ohio demonstrating against the war for
5,600 military personnel a year now
according to Ralph Nader here's one
profession who takes your tax money in
the form of Medicare and Medicaid turns
around and killed 300,000 of you a year
and you can't even find a crazy street
preacher out here in any corner
protesting it all you find are people
lined up with these electronic town-hall
meeting saying Hillary Hillary we've got
to have more of that stuff free find a
way to tax me so I can get it free and
I'm from Missouri so I haven't figured
out
now one of the things you've seen
recently is advertisements and
newspapers this actually comes from a
full-page ad the New York Times on HMOs
and doctors clinics and they put their
faces and pictures in there and ten
years ago if they would have done this
the state medical board would have taken
away their licenses for unethical
practices they used to say five years
ago even after all of those only quacks
and chiropractors have been advertised
in newspapers and phone books but now
the doctors are just you know the
medical doctors are just shoving
everybody out of the way to do this and
what they're trying to say is that if
you join our HMO and give us this
monthly fee we'll give you a whole team
of doctors for the price of one I mean
you're gonna get everything doesn't
matter if you need a head amputated or
weren't taking off your toe you get a
whole team for the price of one actually
this means that you have a 500% increase
in risk of being damaged
[Applause]
now just about one year ago Ralph Nader
came out with another survey this
happened to be in the front page of
every newspaper in the land and of
course because this happened in July of
1994 this is the time of a baseball
strike and people were jumping right to
the sports page and missing this so I
saved it for you
this happens to be from the front page
of the USA Today and Ralph Nader said
one year ago 70% of the medical doctors
who treat Medicare patients in America
flunked the exam on how to prescribed
them safely and effectively 70% now what
would happen to American Airlines of 70%
of the pilots flunked the exam on how to
fly what would happen to American
Airlines as they killed 300,000
passengers a year and why is there this
difference between our acceptance of
what an airline does and what the
medical profession does here's an
example of what Ralph Nader was talking
about said 32,000 hip fractures each
year are attributed to prescribing by
medical doctors that leaves the elderly
unbalanced and dizzy
they try to avoid stepping on the
grandkid and they fall and break a hip
or they might get out of the bathtub or
step out of the car and they break a hip
or slide down the stairs and this is a
death sentence for 29,000 of them
remember 75% of the people over age 65
fractured hip for major Lake bone don't
live 90 days and I believe the only way
to stop this is to make physicians
responsible for this the same way that
we make bartenders responsible when they
give people too many drinks and let them
drive home and they kill somebody else
for themselves and you know we put about
500 to 1,000 doctors in jail for life
without parole
they'll start paying attention to
decimal points on the outside yeah now
here's a quick look at the medications
that should not be given to people over
the age of 65 if they're up walking
around this is from Ralph Nader and the
PDR the physicians Desk Reference
and of course 70% of American doctors do
prescribe these things on a regular
basis to people over age 65 are looking
at high blood pressure medications blood
thinners pain relievers diabetic
medications arthritis medications
tranquilizer sleeping pills and this is
the basis of the problem now who is it
that they kill is it just the homeless
you know medical students go out in the
dark of the night and they're VW van and
collect the homeless and take them into
the basements of the medical centers and
and hospitals and practice on them I
know it doesn't matter if you're
homeless or you live in a big house it
doesn't matter if you're rich or poor or
if you're an embryo or a toddler or a
teenager middle age or a senior it
doesn't matter if you're educated or
uneducated if you go to a hospital
you're at risk
now here's a quick example this little
gal here Betsy layman how many of you
remember her story it was just a couple
of months ago April half a dozen that's
amazing Betsy layman 39 years old was
getting treated for breast cancer at age
39 and she was getting the last of a
series of chemotherapy treatments over a
period of five months and she was the
top medical reporter for the Boston
Globe which is a second largest
newspaper in the United States and she
examined the records of all these cancer
treatment centers and chose the Dana
Farber Cancer Institute in Boston
because to her it was the best in the
world and on their last treatment they
gave her a four-day dose every day for
four days they gave her 16 times
overdosed and killed this 39 year old
woman with an overdose of chemotherapy
even though she was the top medical
reporter for the Boston Globe and here's
one to leave and ring your bell even
more Jackie Kennedy this picture was
taken of her and I lift it out of a
magazine because I think it's
significant this picture was taken of
her three days before she entered the
hospital for chemotherapy for the first
treatment for cancer she doesn't look
like a terminal cancer patient she was
taking a stroll around Central Park on
her brisk day with a friend and she was
diagnosed six months before her death
with non-hodgkins lymphoma which is a
type of cancer that normally takes 10 12
15 years to kill you it's relatively
painless and Jackie had 15 years left
when she was diagnosed there was no
death watch on her when she entered the
hospital for her chemotherapy her first
treatment there was no reporter standing
out there and giving you 15 minute
updates she kind of waved the press am
going in for some chemotherapy no big
deal and nobody made a big hoo-ha
Tuesday she was dead four days later she
was dead you were supposed to believe
the Jackie Kennedy died of cancer well
I'm a pathologist as well as a clinician
and I can guarantee asurs God made
little green apples Jackie Kennedy did
not die cancer she was killed with an
overdose of chemotherapy
just like Betsy layman same now if they
can kill the top Medical reporter from
The Boston Globe they can kill a Jackie
Kennedy and not a single doctor was
suspended they didn't find the hospital
nobody was sued what chance to each and
every one of you hands no no no okay no
no no no now this goes on according to
Ralph Nader because simply agreed
doctors don't want to start a landslide
of having problems and so they just kind
of ignore all these things and this
happened to be from the Washington Post
editorial page November 2nd 1992 and the
headline said the lining Doc's pockets
if you go to your doctor you want him to
think of you as a patient not a cash cow
you farmers know what a cash cow is
right that's where you milk them and you
don't drink the milk you sell it to pay
your bills but two studies in this
month's New England Journal of Medicine
the top medical journal in America shows
the doctor
to milk you dry then ten months later in
one of my favorite little magazines
Reader's Digest there's a great little
article and to me that Reader's Digest
is the sweetest little magazine that
ever was never says anything negative
about any individual or group
I mean it's so neutral you find it in
the waiting rooms of politicians and
lawyers and doctors I mean it doesn't
offend anybody but in this issue
September 1993 on page 77 it says can
you trust your doctor and at lists 12
ways that doctors routinely scam money
from patients and insurance I'll just
give you the worst one you go look up
the other 11 according to Reader's
Digest not Joel Wallach doctors in
America get 421 dollars in kickbacks
every time they send you in for a cat
scan or an MRI doc really cares about me
he sent in the infrared mark I just had
this shoulder pain - King now according
to Reader's Digest
according to Reader's Digest NOT Joel
Wallach the average doctor in America
each year gets two hundred and twenty
six thousand six hundred eighty one
dollars and can't scan and MRI kickbacks
that's almost a quarter of a million
dollars and you wonder why insurance
keeps going up and you can't afford
medical care now one of my favorite
surveys from Harvard Medical School was
put out 1972 and what they did was look
at the use of illegal drugs by medical
doctors and they looked at the illegal
use of prescription drugs by medical
doctors what they found out was pretty
terrifying what they found out in 1972
was that 52% of all licensed medical
doctors in America used psychotropic
drugs illegally every week 52 percent
every week now you're looking at speed
cocaine marijuana opium derivatives and
other drugs like fentanyl anesthetics
and so forth and so next time you go to
a doctor if you still choose to go after
tonight
don't be too excited about the degrees
he has hanging on the wall you want to
look at the pupils of his eyes and see
if he's gorked out before you let him
diagnose
[Applause]
or do surgery on you then even scarier
yet were 78% of the medical students
used psychotropic drugs illegally every
week 78% here's an example this fellow
here was a pediatrician of his obituary
appeared in the front page of the Union
Tribune in San Diego December of 1994
and he was a 30 year old pediatrician
took care of babies right and he died of
a self-inflicted overdose of these
recreational drugs and said eulogizing
said oh he saved the lives of children
but lost his own in the article it said
he devoted his whole life to caring for
children well he must have been a
babysitter most of his life because he
was only out of school medical school
for three years is 30 years old and he
was a thief because the drugs he killed
himself with he stoled from the hospital
pharmacy and he was malignant dumb
because after 14 years in medical school
he still couldn't read a syringe
properly and he overdosed himself I mean
even these high school dropouts is live
in cardboard boxes don't kill themselves
with drugs right they just go on and on
like these pink rabbits near 80
god works in mysterious ways and took
him out of the loop for us I mean you
wouldn't want him taking care of your
kids our grandkids would you his
nickname in medical school was the
social director because he was the one
who could always get the drugs in
alcohol for the medical students now you
can always learn a lot from obituaries
that's another one of my hobbies is
collecting obituaries and you know you
can learn what's going on in a community
how good the doctors are by reading
obituaries in the community and so this
one fascinated me grace Mysterio 48
years old died of breast cancer not
unusual tragically but certainly a waste
of humanity but this little tale on the
headline given radiation is a baby
concerned me so I read her obituary in
detail then took that information and
went to the medical school and dug out
some facts and basically when she was 6
months old her pediatrician shrunk her
thymus gland with radiation
high doses of radiation because he felt
it was too big he doesn't have any
yardstick to determine whether was too
big too small just felt it was too big
large thymus gland just means you have a
robust immune system you want a large
thymus gland begins to shrink the day
you're born you don't want a small one
and between 1945 and 1950s rain machine
as an army surplus or military surplus
for about 25 bucks no instructions no
restrictions no handbook they just said
here doc here's your x-ray machine go
x-ray them and according to the
Department of Energy between 1945 and
1951 million American babies had their
thymus glands shrunk with radiation by
pediatricians 1 million American babies
now again according the Department of
Energy each and every one of these
people have either already died of
cancer are currently under treatment for
cancer are projected to get cancer
because of the radiation they got in
their chest to shrink their thymus
glands I want you to remember that not a
single foreign enemy has ever radiated
in America
military or civilian and here's one
profession let loose with x-ray machines
radiated 1 million healthy American
babies trust me my dear I'm a doctor I
wonder what the pupils look like in the
eyes of this surgeon that morning when
this doctor took off the normal breast
and left the cancer is one on this woman
and Grand Rapids Michigan I guarantee
you that no sober surgeon could do that
they have an x-ray hanging on the wall
of the surgery room they have a wax red
wax pencil you know the big Earl is
saying that's the one doc you know and
if he's the sort of guy that's dyslexic
they put a red ribbon around his arm and
say you take off of that one and so you
know that this guy had to be worked out
on something this one here was a
neurosurgeon he took the skull off his
patient began operating on the brain and
he had the munchies according to the
article had to run out for 25 minutes
and go eat something I don't believe
that's true cuz I've done a lot of
surgery and even if you get hungry you
don't run out in the middle of an
operation I believe he was one of those
52% of the medical doctors who were on
cocaine and he's getting withdrawal
symptoms and had go snort something in
the bathroom and recover before he went
back and he left the nurse with a black
& decker drill drilling holes in this
patients head
and she injured the patient so he got
his license suspended for 30 days I mean
he's a doctor he spent 14 years in
school he deserves to get his money back
right this one here is kind of
interesting wonder what his what this
surgeons pupils look like he was from
the osteopathic medical center of Texas
and he promptly removed the normal lung
of a patient left the cancer as one in
he settled for nine million dollars why
didn't he go to court and fight it now
one of the basic things you'd like to
see physicians learn in medical school
is whether a patient is alive or dead
that should be basic training right
you'd like to think so but you never
know when you see stuff like this in the
newspaper
now this gal was 86 years old and she
was found cold stiff and blue and her
her nursing home apartment and of course
the doctor there came up and couldn't
find her pulse on just a simple
examination he says oh look she's 86
years old let's let her slip away
quietly let's not do anything heroic
here and run up the cost for the family
so they called the coroner's wagon they
hauled her body off to the hospital in
the local area and the house doctor is
not gonna let you put a body into the
hospital more unless there's a death
certificate so he comes down he examines
her he couldn't find the pulse he's okay
she's dead writes a death certificate
they strip her down hose her body down
put her in a body bag and put her in a
freezer for 90 minutes until the coroner
gets there to do an autopsy they wheel
her out after 90 minutes and freezer is
open the body bag she sits up and says
oh thank God you found me it was cold
and dark in there and I didn't know
where I was
she had to be a tough old bird
you try hosing yourself down getting
naked in a freezer for 90 minutes and
see how well you do
now do you think those doctors really
cared about her now this guy was famous
Willy King at the University Community
Hospital in Tampa Florida
he had gangrene of his right leg and he
went into the hospital to get his right
leg amputated because he had
uncontrolled diabetes and of course when
you have gangrene the meat stinks like
rotten meat in the garbage I mean you
can't miss it the skin and slipping off
and bones are showing through and it's a
real mess and the surgeon promptly
amputated his normal left leg I'm even a
Cub Scout wouldn't do that and so I know
that he was gorked out on something a
couple more here and we'll get into the
concept number two I know that's why
you're here but I think you have to know
this stuff so you really pay attention
to concept number two metal student
arrested for illegal sale of weapons I
don't believe that he made a habit of
selling guns the street gangs I keepers
caught for I believe he was one of the
78% of the medical students who were
doing cocaine and the street gangs
blackmailed him said hey if you don't
buy us some guns we'll tell people
you're using cocaine and you'll never
practice so I'm glad he's out of the
loop too another one of those very moral
high ethical medical people a couple
more here
insurers are now getting swamped with
disability claims by doctors these are
doctors who have sold their practices to
HMOs now when they're in private
practice they gross fifty thousand one
hundred thousand dollars a month and of
course they get to play with the money
if they're a specialist like a
cardiologist an orthopedic surgeon they
gross a quarter of a million or half a
million dollars a month and what they do
of course is if they want to buy a
Mercedes they don't pay interest on it
for ten years they just take a late
payment on their house pave ten percent
for a late fee and they plopped down
$100,000 on a Mercedes they get to play
with that money now once they sell their
practice to an HMO the HMO keeps all
that money have to pay the nurses and
the insurance and all the
you know and all this kind of stuff and
the doctor gets a paycheck ten thousand
dollars a month now do you and me that
sounds like a lot of money but to an
orthopedic surgeon that sticker shot and
he kind of says oh my god what did I do
here and then he starts looking at the
benefits why did I become employee of
this HMO and he learns that his
disability check is going to be $20,000
a month he figures why should I practice
and risk losing my house and my car from
you know a malpractice suit work hard
get up at four o'clock in the morning do
surgery when all I have to do is oh got
a back problem here and it's real easy
to get a golf buddy to say he blew a
disc and suddenly now he can collect
twenty thousand a month and that's
what's happening now these doctors are
so used to stealing money from patients
and insurance there was no big mental
leap for them to do that last one
concept number one why you need to take
care of yourself and how to avoid the
landmines is this trust gap this between
doctors and patients everybody knows
that doctors treat the symptoms rather
than getting down to the root cause of
things that's no secret and some of the
greatest cartoons today about doctors
you see this little granny going into
the doctor's office and she's got law
books and a PDR and a Merck Manual and
she's got a big thug with her to beat up
on the doctor and a lawyer and all this
sort of stuff and so you know that
there's this trust gap and doctors know
this and my daddy when I grew up in the
farm he'd say things to me like Joel if
you do anything in this community if you
make anybody in this community feel that
we're liars or we're dishonest I will
personally burn you at the stake now
that made an impression on me when I was
a kid
roasted marshmallows looked like and I
didn't want to be burned at the stake
and so I mean even on Halloween I never
dumped over outhouses I was very careful
but and I would like to see ethics
professors and medical schools tell
their medical students look if you do
anything to a patient if you teat a
patient severe dishonest with a patient
I will personally come to your practice
and strangle you to death
I would like to see them say things like
that but they don't here's what's
happening in medical schools doctors are
now urging or medical professors are now
urging medical students to take acting
lessons so they can convince patients
they love them instead of getting down
to the root cause of things and just
being honest they're learning how to act
so they think convince you how to that
they love you okay that's concept number
one those are all the reasons one why
you want to take control of your own
health and I'm really genuinely so happy
to see so many people here who are
interested in information in their own
health
now concept number two once you've
survived long enough for concept number
two to kick in what you have to do is
give your body all of the 90 essential
nutrients every day that it needs to
maintain a repair itself we need 60
minerals we need 16 vitamins we need 12
essential amino acids three essential
fatty acids and they're called essential
nutrients because each and every one of
them are required every day to prevent
one or more diseases on the average
about ten diseases per nutrient there's
90 essential nutrients times ten
diseases it's nine hundred diseases that
you can prevent and theoretically
reverse with nutrition that's to me is
very spectacular the second part of the
definition of something that's essential
is your body cannot make it and so you
must eat it every day you must take it
in every day now the media knows you're
interested in health and nutrition
that's why 90% of you're here because
you heard our interviews on the radio
and it doesn't matter whether it's radio
or TV or newspapers or magazines
everybody's talking about health low
cholesterol diet low fat diets high
fiber diets
eat my pounds of broccoli a day all that
kind of stuff right well my favorite
article of all time from the media from
the hard press any weight what they call
hard Inc is Time magazine the real power
of vitamins new research shows they may
help fight heart disease cancer and the
ravages of aging the first time that the
subject of vitamins and minerals and
supplementation was in fact talked about
in a positive way for the American
people in a mainstream publication again
the real power of vitamins new research
shows it may help by cancer heart
disease and the ravages of aging there
were six positive pages in that article
if you haven't read it I urge you to go
to a public library of school library
and get it
there was only one negative sentence
that was given as you might expect by a
medical doctor who's asked by the writer
of the article what do you think about
vitamins and minerals as supplements for
human nutrition here's what this medical
doctor said quote popping vitamins
doesn't do you any good sniffs dr.
Victor Herbert a professor of medicine
at New York City's Mount Sinai Medical
School we get all the vitamins we need
in our diets and taking supplements just
gives you expensive urine unquote now a
Missouri translation of that is you're
just peeing away your money if you take
vitamins and minerals you might as well
take your dollars throw them in a toilet
and flush them away because you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups that's what he was trying to say
I can tell you after having done those
17,500 autopsies and over four hundred
and fifty four species of animals plus
three thousand human beings practicing
in a general family practice for 12
years of Portland Oregon
and pushing 60 myself and having kids
this big and grandkids this big and
not-too-distant future great grandkids
I'd rather pee out 50 cents or $1 day
worth of excess vitamins and minerals
because it's a cheap insurance it's a
cheap investment in yourself to keep
yourself healthy and if you don't invest
50 cents to $1 day in yourself assures
God made little green apples you're
going to invest in the lifestyle of a
medical doctor because when you pay that
doctor bill not one penny of that you
know whether it's out of your own pocket
directly I think I got some change in
here yeah I have your own pocket
directly or indirectly through insurance
or indirectly through being taxed so you
can pay Medicare and Medicaid and then
have them pay the doctor now one single
penny of that goes to better understand
manage prevent your catastrophic
diseases and kids or breast cancer in
women prostate cancer and men
diabetes heart disease it doesn't do any
of that it simply pays the doctor's
mortgage you pay the doctor bill after
the second week of the month you're
paying his Mercedes payment you pay the
doctor bill after the third week of the
month you're paying for the tuition for
his kids to go to medical school would
have it up and buy him worse yet he
might even be Yale Law School it's all
we needed some more Yale lawyers running
around we got two of them in the White
House you see what's going on there
now I believe that the medical
profession I believe that the medical
profession should in fact give people
information on a free basis because
they're the only profession the only
trade that we have guaranteed will not
fail you ask your employer to take half
the insurance premium out of your
paycheck okay
and you argue you know as a union you
you you try and get them to pay this
insurance premium you to make sure that
doctor gets paid you don't do that for
farmers or cops or butchers or
carpenters or plumbers you only do that
for doctors and you bake your government
to tax you to death so they can pay
Medicare for you
you don't do that for cops or farmers or
anybody else you only do that for
doctors so at the very least I believe
the medical profession owes the American
public some information now how many of
you get to sent photocopies from
newspapers and scientific articles from
your doctors every week or every month
showing a positive things you can do
your medical doctors
isn't it amazing no hands up okay I'll
show you what I give my patients every
week and every month so you know what
you should be getting number one if you
take home nothing more than what I'm
going to show you here in the next three
slides it will have been worth you're
coming here tonight let's just start out
with cancer it's the number two killer
of Americans and of course the war on
cancer was declared 1971 by Nixon and
Congress agreed that the American
government should jump in and deal with
this terrible disease and they committed
twenty three billion dollars to finding
a cure in a vaccine for cancer in over a
period of twenty four years finally they
were called up before Congress to give a
progress report they say okay what did
you do with our twenty three billion
dollars what have you done over twenty
four years and they said well
unfortunately the rate of cancer has
gone up in America since 1971 by
eighteen percent and we spent your
twenty three billion dollars but we
don't have any vaccines or cures but
that's because we were in the wrong
position we weren't
right and what we want now is we want a
medical doctor on the president's
cabinet we want him to be called the
cancers are and we want his office to
have 60 million dollars a year so he can
fly around the country and tell people
it's better to take chemotherapy and
radiation so reduce the cancer death
rate well I'm glad we have a
conservative Congress in there right now
because they're gonna tell these doctors
were the SH of that request because the
definition of insanity is to keep doing
the same thing over and over and over
and over again expect a different
outcome now we've been doing
chemotherapy and radiation for 30 years
and the rate of cancer has gone up 18
percent now what they say is well we've
been doing it only during the daytime
now we want the money so we can try it
at night for 23 years
[Music]
now I don't want you to wait for your
government or don't even wait for your
doctor to give you permission to do this
thing for cancer can you do this you
start it tonight and you will save
yourself an enormous amount of money and
unnecessary misery this is the real
answer for cancer this study was done by
the National Cancer Institute not the
national enquirer we're talking about
the most highly funded research agency
in the world and they not only get money
from Americans but they get money from
governments from all over the world
because everybody in fact is terrified
of cancer what they did was go to Henan
Province China
they went to Henan Province China and
they chose there to do their study
because it has the highest rate of
cancer in the whole world and they took
29,000 people over a period of five
years between the ages of 40 and 69 they
gave them different vitamins and
minerals and combinations of vitamins
and minerals they're the little groups
to determine if this had any positive
effect on reducing the rate of cancer in
this place that has the worst cancer
rate in the whole world to make a long
story short when they gave single
nutrients not much happened remember
Linus Pauling took ten thousand
milligrams of vitamin C every day for 35
years still died of cancer and so you
shouldn't be too surprised when they
gave double the American RDA which is
120 milligrams of vitamin C every day
for five years it didn't affect the rate
of cancer
vitamin A or retinol didn't affect the
rate of cancer zinc riboflavin the trace
mineral molybdenum niacin none of those
things affected the rate of cancer and
Enon province but one group did show
significant benefit this group got three
nutrients even though as pitifully small
doses just double the American RDA they
got beta-carotene vitamin E in the trace
mineral selenium every day for five
years they showed significant benefit
they reduced the death rate from all
causes death from all causes reduced by
9%
that included diabetes and stroke and
heart disease and cancer and accidents
and suicide and so on they reduced the
cancer death rate by 13% when you just
looked at cancer and the type of cancer
that was most common in Henan Province
China stomach and esophageal cancer they
reduced by 21 percent just by giving 20
cents a day worth of three nutrients you
add up 21 percent they got better and 18
percent we got worse that's 39 percent
better off they are
we just simply by taking 20 cents a day
worth of 3 nutrients and if you get that
notice from your doctor or your
government or okay
so I urge you to do this on your own
don't wait for permission from anybody
now my favorite disease and and the
reason why many of you are here tonight
is arthritis arthritis affects 75
percent of all Americans over the age of
50 and there's not a single medical
treatment designed to fix it and I find
that fascinating any disease that
affects 70 percent of the people over
age 50 in America and there's no
treatment designed to fix it tells me
that somebody's got their head in the
wrong place there must not be any money
in fixing it at a rate for 25 years I've
been giving my patients what I call dr.
Wallach Pig arthritis formula and I'm
gonna give you that complete formula in
just a minute but right now I just tell
you that dr. Wallach Pig arthritis
formula has regrown cartilage for
thousands and thousands of people even
though it can't be done
this was the professor of medicine the
guy who's in charge of this study he
said quote after three months it was
clear that the drug was beneficial
unquote instead of saying well Wallach
was right this stuff really works
instead he turned it into a drug in
ninety days because you can patent drugs
and little sugar plums dancing through
his head to change the change took him
off of all their medication they gave
him a heaping tablespoonful around up
chicken cartilage in their orange juice
every morning for 90 days in ten days
they had complete relief of pain and
inflammation in just 10 days something
they hadn't had in 15 to 20 years in 30
days they could open up a new pickle jar
without pain to the fingers wrists
elbows and shoulder in 90 days 28 out of
the 29 had a complete clinical cure
according to Harvard Medical School
here's the part that I find fascinating
this is where the medical profession
really shows their colors now they
charge thirty five hundred dollars a
month for little capsules of chicken
cartilage in Harvard Medical School so
if you don't want to contribute to the
delinquency of a medical doctor all you
have to do is go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken buy a final bucket of chicken
throw away the meat eat the ends off the
bones you get
and if you have several people in your
family that have arthritis yet could get
a little pricey buying $5 buckets of
chicken you could take your grandkids or
kids in the dark of the night with a
five-gallon empty feed buckets go to the
dumpster behind the KFC let them scoop
out all those chicken bones for you take
them home put them on a cookie sheet put
them in the oven and bake them dry take
your ball peen hammer mash them into a
flour fill those capsules yourself but
don't let your neighbors or friends or
relatives know what you're doing to
because if you let it get out the FDA is
going to come arrest you for
manufacturing pharmaceuticals without a
license or even worse yet Janet's going
to come save you from yourself and burn
your house down
[Applause]
so if that seems a little messy for
illegal or you don't want to mess with
those gushy chicken bones all you have
to do is go to a grocery store a good
pharmacy or a health food store and get
some Knox gelatin KMOX and most ladies
know about Knox gelatin because it's
good for the split ends on their hair
and the brittle fingernails and skin
quality and I'm going to give you that
complete formula in just a minute but
right now I just tell you that dr.
Wallach Spig arthritis formula has
regrown cartilage for thousands and
thousands of people even though it can't
be done now Alzheimers is another one we
didn't have Alzheimer's disease 2,000
years ago otherwise it would've been the
eighth plague that Moses laid on the
Pharaoh right I mean it's a terrible
disease we didn't have it a hundred
years ago we only began to see
alzheimers disease in America after the
Second World War when we switched from
butter to margarine this is a doctor a
physician cause disease Alzheimer is a
physician cause disease because they've
urged everybody to give up butter and go
to margarine and I'll prove this chain a
minute now we learned how to prevent and
cure 65% of the Alzheimer's disease in
animals 50 years ago can you imagine a
dairy farmer with a 500 head of dairy
cows way out in the pasture and he's
shaking the feed bucket and yelling to
him you and the cows are out there
scratching their heads saying why do we
want to go to the barn
and if we did where is it you'd have to
pump gas into the ATV and run out there
and get him we're on the price of milk
out and so we learn how to prevent
Alzheimer's disease and cure it and
lifestyle just for those reasons and we
did this with aloe vegetable oil diet
that's rich in vitamin E and selenium
now most people at this point say not
come on Wallach now we stuck with you
with a cancer thing with vitamin E and
selenium and beta-carotene because we
heard that before is no big surprise and
although we never heard this cartilage
thing with arthritis it makes sense give
the body the raw materials and it'll
rebuild itself but aren't aren't you
kind of pushing a little bit here aren't
just stretching it with this vitamin E
thing and in Alzheimers I mean Ralph
Nader says it's the fourth leading cause
of death and Americans over the age of
65 now it went from zero fifty years ago
to now it's the fourth leading cause of
death and seniors over age 65 I mean it
could really be nutrition well you
should have gotten a two-cent photo copy
of this news release or the scientific
paper from your doctor's the three years
ago July 1992 this is from the
University of California at San Diego
School of Medicine not from the National
Enquirer vitamin E can ease memory loss
and Alzheimer's victims how many of you
got that notice from your doctor nobody
remember the doctors own 51% of the
stock and the nursing home that takes
care of Alzheimer's patients my personal
pet peeve is birth defects we're able to
prevent 98% of all birth defects and
animals and we do this is what we call
preconception nutrition it's so
effective we're even able to prevent
birth defects that are considered to be
genetic in humans we can prevent Down
syndrome cystic fibrosis muscular
dystrophy heart defects of all kinds
club limbs missing limbs hernias
biochemical defects such as epilepsy and
PKU and other things like that we
prevent 98% of these in animals with
with what we call preconception
nutrition we give the female animal for
our 60 to 90 days before they can see
before AI or before natural breeding we
give them all these vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals and
essential amino acids and fatty acids
so when the embryo begins to develop it
begins to develop immediately in optimal
nutrition in humans we wait till the
woman misses one or two or three
menstrual periods she then goes to the
OB and gets the blessing yes my dear
you're pregnant now you may have your
prescription for prenatal vitamins and
minerals now the human brain spinal cord
heart and other major organs farm in the
first 28 days of pregnancy if the woman
gets the prenatal vitamins and minerals
at the 30th day or the 45th day or the
60th day does it protect the embryo in
any way no absolutely not and as a
result the birth defect rate in America
this was just published two months ago
by the University of California San
Francisco the birth defect rate in
America now is 1 out of 33 babies in
America is born with some kind of defect
either physical emotional or mental one
out of 33 if you look at animals that
receive pellets or cake that have
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
in it the birth defect rate in those
animals receiving commercial or prepared
diets is one out of 500,000 compared to
one in 33 for humans now you should have
gotten this notice especially you ladies
to go to Obi's three years ago the CDC
Center for Disease Control came out and
said the women who were sexually active
whether they plan a pregnancy or not
should be taking vitamins and minerals
so if a pregnancy does occur the embryo
is immediately protected for 40 bucks of
pregnancy we can prevent 98% of all
birth defects and all the human misery
that goes along with it okay let's
change pace a little bit I want to ask
you some questions how many of you have
ever heard that vegetable oils are
healthier for you than that terrible
saturated animal fat with you believe it
or not how many of you heard it good
that's pretty good then this group's
about 70% the other 30% or either a
sleep line or have Alzheimers because I
know
I know you've heard it I know you've
heard it now we knew fifty years ago in
the animal industry that vegetable aisle
was dangerous because we tried to get
animals to gain weight faster by giving
them 20% of their calories in their
rations Cornell or soil because oil and
fat has nine calories per gram compared
with carbohydrate or crack corn has four
and a half calories per gram the more
calories per mouthful the faster the
animals would get out of the feed lot
less labor less feed and more profit for
the farmers it was a good theory to look
at but for the first couple of weeks
these animals getting Cornell or soil in
their ration did gain weight much faster
than the ones without it but at six
weeks they all died of heart attacks so
we knew it was a good idea that went
sour somewhere along the line and so
what do we do now we've contracted with
farmers to grow millions of tons of soy
oil and carnal each year for the next 25
years and no farmers dumb enough to give
this stuff to his livestock so what are
we doing and one guy popped up and said
well it's not proven in humans yet we'll
just convince people it's good for them
until it's proven otherwise
well that was 35 years ago and the news
came out three well two and a half years
ago said to vegetable oil can cause
heart disease it's a nightmare said dr.
Edwin emkin a specialist in food oils
for the US Department of Agriculture is
really a nasty thing when you try to
explain it there's now total confusion
for consumers why would there be
confusion because the truth is different
from what you've been taught now here's
another look at the same problem
little over two years ago this was a
study that was done by Harvard Medical
School and was called the Harvard Nurses
Health Study they took ninety thousand
nurses divided them up into two groups
half of them 45,000 nurses they made
them use butter as their spread on their
crackers and bread and cooking
shortening the other half the other
45,000 they made him use margarine as
their spreading their crackers and bread
and cooking sharpening and after 20
years they looked at the nurses who had
died of a heart attack and for every
hundred nurses who had died of a heart
attack 70 I've worn the margarine group
two and a half times greater risk of
dying of heart attack if you used
margarine how many of you got that from
your doctor yeah the USDA actually sent
that around to all doctors now I typed a
PS on there from me to my patients and I
said look because of this what I want
you to do is box up all your margarine
your salad dressings your cooking oil
and ship it to a communist not only will
it save
not only will it save American lives but
it's more effective than bullets
and you know I don't have a single
patient today that uses margarine now
one of my favorite parts of the survey
is down here said those nurses just who
ate just two cookies a day made with
margarine instead of butter had a 50%
higher risk of dying of a heart attack
just two cookies a day and if you're a
cookie eater you can't just he took heat
to cookie today I know I mean I did a
lot of research when I was a teenager
I know that it takes at least a dozen
cookies to get that sweet sludge in the
bottom of that glass of milk
now one of the greatest pieces of
medical fraud that's ever been
perpetuated against the American public
is this cholesterol thing last year
Americans spent a hundred and seventeen
billion dollars for cholesterol testing
a hundred and seventeen billion dollars
just for cholesterol testing and it
didn't extend the American longevity by
30 seconds they have a sole paranoid
about cholesterol most men know their
cholesterol levels but they don't
remember their anniversary date now how
many of you ever had your doctor tell
you what your body uses cholesterol for
okay because we use it for 25 essential
functions in our body if you don't eat
it your body makes it that's the only
reason it's not classed as an essential
nutrient like calcium and zinc and
copper and vitamin A and B vitamins we
need it for 25 essential functions but
we make some of it and because we make
some of it it cannot be classed as an
essential nutrient yet it really is I'll
just give you the top two you can ask
your doctor why don't you ask your
doctor about the other 23 that would be
real interesting number one 75% of your
brain weight is pure cholesterol 75
percent of your brain waves pure
cholesterol is called myelin is that
fatty stuff remember on the forum we
didn't waste anything we crack open the
heads of sheep and pigs and cattle we
eat the brains with eggs and things are
if you've seen brains in a laboratory or
anatomy lab or something like that in
high school or college our professional
school or tech school you know that our
brain is kind of fatty so P kind of
thing and the reason of course is 75% by
weight pure cholesterol so if you give
up animal fat and cholesterol in your
diet it's not your hips that go first
ladies it's the old squash Oliv
now the reason why I pick on ladies is
because 85% of Alzheimers patients are
women
85% of Alzheimer's patients are women
and if you look at a doctor's waiting
room 85% of the people in the doctor's
waiting room are women and children men
are either too smart or too dumb I don't
know to go to doctors and see rarely see
men go into doctors offices now when
woman gets in the examining room and
doctor says look Francine your blood
cholesterol is too high it's too farty I
want you to rip the chicken skin off the
chicken before you eat it and I want you
to give up red meat she'll say yes
doctor I want you to give up butter and
go to margarine yes doctor I want you to
give up eggs and go to egg beaters yes
doctor and she will leave there and
she'll go home and she'll kill everybody
in the family doing that I mean she will
follow that down to the letter
now when a man hears that same lecture
he starts getting this palsy and started
shaking a little bit
and he goes outside of the doctor's
office has to hold on to the wall he
says how do I recover from this I know
I'll go out and eat a 72-ounce steak yes
and that's why 85% of the Alzheimers
patients are women because women tend to
listen to doctors more than men do now
so here's a case for being stupid
actually helps
so if you want to avoid getting
Alzheimer's disease what you want to do
is eat your 90 nutrients every day
supplement with your 90 nutrients give
yourself the raw materials to
manufacture the myelin or the
cholesterol stuff in your brain and you
want to eat two eggs soft scramble every
morning and butter you know and eat red
meat at least twice so they can tell you
what I eat tonight I had beef ribs and
pork ribs and I mean I eat meat my motto
my personal credo is a day without a
hamburgers like a day without sunshine I
refuse to get a Alzheimer's disease now
if you don't take your husband out to
pig out in Big Macs at least once a week
you're making a mistake
now number two number two is a sex
hormones we make sex hormones out of
cholesterol it's the basic building
block to make sex hormones you ladies
make estrogen out of cholesterol and if
you give up animal fat and cholesterol
trying to make your doctor happy you're
gonna be one miserable puppy going
through menopause okay let me tell you
your own adrenal glands and your own
liver will produce enough estrogen if
you give it all the raw materials the 90
nutrients plus cholesterol where you'll
just sail through menopause without any
problems you won't get this night sweats
and the emotional roller coasters and
the hot flashes and all the other
terrible symptoms of menopause if you
just eat some cholesterol and take in
the 90s now when you go to your doctor
and he tells you to give up cholesterol
and he'll give us Trojan supplements no
the patch or the pill or the shot in
reality he should scream at you until
the blood vessels bulge out in his neck
because using estrogen supplements
increases your risk of breast and
uterine cancer by 78% by 78% and it's
really criminal for them to recommend
estrogen to women however they do it all
the time
chi-ching now if you want to avoid all
the problems that go along with estrogen
supplementation all you have to do is
eat two eggs soft scramble every morning
and butter eat some red meat every day
don't rip the chicken skin off the
chicken before you eat it
I mean Cleopatra never did that and she
never complained about menopause right
I mean it would have been recorded in
history if she'd been seeing they're
frantically ripping chickens you know
now you men don't get off easy you make
testosterone or male sex hormone out of
cholesterol and if somebody's trying to
help you like your government or your
doctor your wife or your kids or
somebody saying hey Dad you got to give
up all this cholesterol after about two
years on a low cholesterol diet you
won't know whether to lead or follow on
the dance floor you're gonna be confused
as your station in life and invariably
after these meetings some gal gets me
off to the side and says hey doc you got
to help me my husband hasn't been
interested in the bedroom for the last
ten years and it's gotten so bad in the
last year he even watches TV after the
national anthem goes off and I say well
do you have him on a low cholesterol
Diane she slept through this part of the
meeting so she thinks I want him on a
low cholesterol she's old yeah I ripped
the chicken skin off before I go to him
there's no red meat in our house and we
use margarine instead of butter and we
use egg beaters instead of eggs I said
well there's your problem you've turned
him into a steer
you might as well have used the old
birdies OHS on him
so you want to get him back in the
bedroom dear what you got to do is get
him to a Gasol's ramble every morning
and butter throwing some red meat once
in a while
and if you want to rip the chicken skin
off of your chicken and give it to him
and you'll know he's ready for the
bedroom again when he starts pawing the
rug and his eyebrows lift up now as
crazy as that sounds I've had a thousand
women come back to me and say hey doc
them eggs really work
now you should have gotten these notices
about cholesterol from your doctor about
two and a half years ago oh no it's
almost three years next month it'll be
three years this is from the University
of California at San Francisco and they
these experts on cholesterol and heart
disease came out and said reluctantly
and they came out and reluctantly
admitted that low levels of cholesterol
are more dangerous for you than high
levels of cholesterol human beings
cholesterol look at this date here
August 11th 1992 because I'm going to
show you the same study just a different
newspaper the human beings cholesterol
should be between 220 and 270 if your
blood cholesterol is 270 it just means
you're sexier than somebody that has a
200 cholesterol and there's no
difference in longevity between a 200
cholesterol and 300 cholesterol she's
saying yeah my 300 misses
okay I'll do it this way sings see it
this is a very interesting comment from
the director of that study a professor
of medicine from the University of
California San Francisco dr. Steven
Holley the world expert on cholesterol
here's what he said quote remember three
years ago now what it comes down to is
there's an extraordinary set of
observations that have occurred that
have emerged this year because for the
first time we have a large enough study
to really see them what he said there
was that for 35 years we've been giving
you misinformation we didn't really know
what we're talking about about
cholesterol and for the first time we
have the real answer is what he said in
this study a 350,000 middle-aged people
6% of them had blood cholesterol is
below 180 he's included bagans people
who didn't eat any animal products at
all it included people who had
absorption problems gallbladder and
liver problems so they couldn't absorb
cholesterol even though they ate it and
then and included people who got
prescription drugs like medicore and
others to get their cholesterol down
they were prescribed by their medical
doctors and over 20 years here's what
they found out that these people who had
blood cholesterol is below 180 they had
a 200% increase in risks of dying of an
intracranial hemorrhage or stroke a 200%
increase in risks they had a 300%
increase in risk of dying of liver
cancer yet a 200% increase in risk of
dying of lung disease such as chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease emphysema
asthma and obviously was many times
worse than that if they smoked
they had a 200% increase in risk of
being depressed and suicidal and killing
themselves and lastly they had a 500%
increase in risk of dying from an
addictive process such as alcohol or
drugs or smoking
now why would anybody want to have a
blood cholesterol below 180 well because
the doctor told you to do it just
remember these are the same bunch of
guys who radiated 1 million American
babies to shrink their normal thymus
glands they come up with all these
cockamamie ideas that will kill you now
5 years ago when I started out in this
lecture tour
I began lecturing 300 days out of each
year for the last 5 years and my wife
and my mother said look we'll support
you if you want to do something that
crazy but we're gonna ask you to do
few things for us they say okay whatever
you guys want to get that support I'll
do it
and the only thing that really asked me
to do that was unusual was to have a
hobby so if I really got off the deep
end and got excited more they're gonna
come after me with a butterfly net and
haul me away and I'd get this Hobby out
of the briefcase study it and calm
myself down so I said okay that's fair
and I sat down I started making a list
of possible hobbies and I looked at
doing crossword puzzles well that's good
mental exercise might help me but didn't
help anybody else and so I went through
a whole list of things trying to find a
hobby that would help other people and I
finally settled on collecting obituaries
of doctors
[Laughter]
now as crazy as that sounds it has a
positive value because if doctors knew
what they were talking about when it
comes to health nutrition longevity and
that kind of thing if you separate them
out from the general population in
America they should be healthier and
live longer right if they know what
they're doing so I did that I went to
the medical library at the Medical
School of San Diego at La Jolla the
north end of town and I spent a week in
there going through all these statistics
and these surveys that were done on
causes of death and doctors and
longevity studies and things what I
found out was pretty shocking bill the
average lifespan for medical doctors in
America is 58 58 the average lifespan
for the average person in America is 75
point five so you can gain 20 years
statistically by not going to medical
school
I brought you a few my favorites so
you'd see what I'm talking about
dr. Stewart cart right here age 38
dropped dead in his home in San Diego
from a ruptured coronary aneurysm a
swelling or a ballooning of the artery
in the heart and of course a aneurysm is
a breakdown of the elastic fibers in the
artery and you get a ballooning in that
weakened area much like a car or truck
tire when you hit a chuckhole and you
break the cords and you get a ballooning
of that area it's very weak and will
blow I always say the dr. Stewart cart
right here died is something even a
turkey wouldn't die from because 1957 we
learned from a turkey study what causes
aneurysms the USDA felt that they knew
enough about Turkey nutrition at that
time they're able to take turkeys off of
the range and put them on concrete or
wire and they built this pellet to do
that and in the first thirteen weeks in
this pilot project where they had
250,000 turkeys on it in the first 13
weeks farmers were out there every
morning picking him up by the bushel
baskets full taking them to the state
diagnostic lab to see what they died
from when they opened him up for the
autopsy every one of them 125,000 of
them had died of a ruptured aortic
aneurysm and one of the clever
pathologist says you know that's got to
be due to a copper deficiency because
copper is required to manufacture
elastic fibers and also maintain a
strength in arteries and skin and other
tissues in the body so they doubled the
amount of copper in there the next year
they tried to raise 500,000 turkeys and
not a single one of those turkeys died
from a ruptured aneurysm they went from
a 50% loss to a zero loss just simply by
doubling the amount of copper in there
they got very excited about this and
they started studying copper deficiency
diseases in humans and varieties species
of animals again to make a long story
short what they found out was this the
first symptom of a copper deficiency in
human beings is white gray or silver
hair even in the dark I see a lot of
copper deficiency in this room now the
medical profession would say well just
color your hair you're gonna treat the
symptom even though you have serious
things going on the inside
and if you don't take this warning if
you don't heed this warning from your
body and don't start supplementing with
some colloidal copper what happens is
you begin to get a breakdown in the
elastic fibers in your skin and you get
the crow's feet around the corners of
your eyes and the corners of your mouth
parts of your Anatomy begin to Sag and
you know you're in trouble when you go
to your doctor for a physical in these
days you know I've got a golf buddy
being a colleague down the hall here
who's a plastic surgeon and for $10,000
so make you look 20 years younger he can
give you a facelift a boobie lift a
tummy tuck a derriere lift and you don't
need any of that surgery really all you
need is some colloidal copper and
everything will come back up like you
have a hydraulic jack under it
now if you don't do something about it
at that point you get a breakdown of the
elastic fibers and the large veins of
your legs and you get varicose veins and
if you don't heed the warning there you
get a breakdown of the elastic fibers in
your exhaust pipe you get hemorrhoids so
so if you have hemorrhoids varicose
veins skin wrinkles or things that sag
gray white or silver hair the odds are
you have some aneurysms growing in you
somewhere and don't be one of these
people who dies suddenly and all your
friends get together at Denny's you know
after the funeral are all still dressed
up in their Gladrags and they say you
know we never would have thought the
Frank would be the first one to go I
mean this guy was mr. Fitness he jogged
every morning he belonged to the health
club went and did Arabic three times a
week he had his little bike at home -
this thing he was a vegetarian I mean
this guy was mr. Fitness he always
looked so handsome so distinguished in
his gray hair
now another one of my favorites is dr.
Martin Carter his age 57 died one year
before they averaged for physicians and
he was an expert according to the New
York Times obituaries he had every drop
of medical education you could get in
the whole world let's see here he got
his undergraduate degree his pre-med
stuff from Dartmouth College scuse me
Dartmouth you can't say the arse of New
England from Dartmouth College he
received his MD from habit of food
boston and he got his PhD degree from
medicine in medicine from yale he had
every drop of medical education you get
in the whole world but he didn't have
expensive urine the cause of death was a
ruptured aortic aneurysm just like those
copper deficient turkeys now this guy
here I have to give you a quick quote so
you won't think ill of me before I show
you his obituary Clarence Darrow was
very famous he was kind of a F lee
Bailey a trial attorney back a defense
attorney back in the 20s and he was made
famous by a variety of trials including
the Scopes Monkey Trial in Tennessee and
the prosecutor who always fought him in
court was William Jennings Bryan both of
them were great orders and they're
always fighting each other in court and
on the lecture circuit and whatnot and a
week after that trial William Jennings
Bryan had actually won the trial of
prosecution one and he died suddenly
after that trial and all the reporters
and all the media ran ran and rushed to
Clarence Darrow because they knew they
had this blood feud between him and he
said well why you must have really been
rough on the William Jennings Bryan
cause he just died it was just shortly
after that trial and Clarence Darrow
knew this was the last chance he'd have
to take a dig at his old buddy and he
knew that if he died first it would be
the other way around so this is a very
famous quote here's what he said quote
oh I hate to see anybody die but there
have been a few obituaries I've enjoyed
reading unquote
that's kind of how I feels about this
guy dr. Thomas beam age 48 died 10 years
before the average for physicians 30
years before the average for the average
American on the street he was an expert
according to the New York Times
obituaries and he died of a simple core
team up with the heart attack a selenium
deficiency and not only was he an expert
he was an FDA expert why would you want
to listen to anything the FDA had to say
about health and nutrition when their
experts are diagnosed selenium
deficiency disease at age 48 my mother's
favorite obituaries and first my mother
76 years old and she collects these
things when I'm out on the road she gets
all these newspaper subscriptions from
all around the Midwest and when I get
home I always have this envelope of
plain brown envelopes as personal and
confidential and she's got she got
obituaries of politicians lawyers and
doctors in there
I mean she's expanded the theory right
and so this is her favorite dr. Gayle
Clarke 47 was not only a cardiologist
who she was the chief cardiologist of
her own Hospital and she was walking
down the halls of her own Hospital with
a stethoscope hi I'm dr. Gil Clark chief
cardiologist here's my stethoscope boom
she dropped dead right there in the
hospital in all her colleagues you know
they're screaming for code carts and
residents and interns and House doctors
everybody's trying to save dr. Clark to
the the chief cardiologist and they're
trying to save her next to you and you
hear this all this activity you hear I'm
cutting the clothes off this patient an
emergency going on and you hear them say
okay bring up the paddles turn it on
okay put on contact gel everybody clear
here clear everybody here we go
it didn't work so they say okay turn it
up to the next step more contact Gel
clear everybody and they turn on the
monitor so you hear you know that
flatlines you know they're dead and your
monitor is going because you're nervous
your heart patient you say nurse nurse
what happened next sir I heard all this
chaos and screaming and everything and
say well you know your cardiologist the
chief cardiologist of this hospital dr.
Gail Clark age 47 just croak next door
from a party mop of the heart attack you
can see all the patients holding their
gowns and they're running out of the
hospital as fans I think go
because whatever the chief got they
don't want
I mean man if you can't save the teeth
with it why would you want it you'd like
to think that somebody who won the Nobel
Prize in medicine but at least lives to
be the average of seventy five point
five this guy here was the youngest
person ever to win the Nobel Prize in
medicine he was 38 years old
excuse me 37 37 years old won the Nobel
Prize in medicine 11 years later he died
of a cardiomyopathy heart attack
simple selenium deficiency disease so I
always tell people whatever a doctor
tells you do the opposite you'll live
longer
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
now remember my job when I came back
from Africa it was to find an early
warning system and I believe I found it
it's not an exotic animal like a koala
bear a wallaby or anything like that and
they're a hummingbird or maybe a hope we
have a drug dealer in the group
he's either licensed or unlicensed but
he's a drug dealer
is not a rare fish or reptile in fact
the early warning system that gives us a
clue and what's going on in the world of
health and nutrition is our young
athletes according to the CDC the Center
for Disease Control the Center for
Disease Control what you need to do is
look at athletes 100,000 of them die
each year suddenly during exercise or
immediately after exercise 100,000 even
though doctors say exercise is good for
you I began to see stuff like this over
the last ten years in medical journals
sudden death and young athletes because
it's gotten to be a real thing in the
medical field this is a small study but
it gives you an idea what's going on 29
highly competitive highly conditioned
athletes between the ages of 13 and 30
dropped dead during exercise are
immediately after exercise and 35% died
of ruptured aneurysms what did they die
from copper deficiency the other 65%
died of cardiac myopathy heart disease
they died of a selenium deficiency and
so this began ten years ago to make me
believe that athletes were giving us a
story early on you see the stuff in the
newspapers all the time this happens to
be from Colorado University in Boulder
and this is a kid 22 years old Darin
millat had just signed a multi-million
dollar contract from an NBA team and he
died just while he was shooting some
baskets and I talked to the pathologist
who did the autopsy on him he died of
Kearny MA but the heart disease at age
22 his one is very famous Reggie Lewis
Reggie Lewis was 27 years old he was the
captain of the Boston Celtics he was a
65 million dollar contract athlete and
he collapsed in April of 1993 a little
over two years ago and was diagnosed
very quickly and very accurately with
cardiomyopathy heart disease and because
he was a 65 million dollar contract
athlete the Boston Celtics hired the top
12 cardiologist in the whole world
gave him a million dollars each to refer
all their patients out to other doctors
so they could devote their full time to
saving Reggie because if Reggie died
they had to give 65 million dollars to
his widow now not one of those doctors
not one of those doctors who were called
the dream team of cardiology they were
called the dream team of cardiology
because
the top cardiologist in the whole world
not one of them gave $50 of their
million dollars to a medical student or
a researcher to go to the medical
library and ask the computer what are
all the known causes of cardiomyopathy
heart disease and if they would have
done that kind of like you know Star
Trek computer what are all the known
causes according mildly the computer
would have said the only known cause was
determined in animals in 1957 it was
proven in humans in 1972 17 years later
and this was published in in every
medical journal in the world it was a
double-blind crossover study of 45,000
human subjects and not one of them did
that not one of them oh I should tell
you what what the cause is it's a
selenium deficiency disease it's the
only known cause and they didn't give
Reggie 20 cents worth of selenium and as
a result he died from his second carny
mob with a heart attack three months
later July 28th 1993 now justice has a
way of coming around remember the dream
team of cardiology and you know what's
coming
a year and a half later the captain of
the dream team of Cardiology dr. Thomas
Nova aged 48 boom drop dead from Kearney
myopathy in his own home the same thing
that Reggie died from a year and a half
ago he didn't learn anything from a 65
million dollar autopsy now I'd have been
embarrassed to put this in the newspaper
if I was his family it says dr. Thomas
Nessa a member of the dream team of
cardiologists who treated the late
Boston Celtics captain Reggie Lewis died
Saturday his home blah blah blah from
the same thing I mean I would have just
put a little thing in the classified ads
it said Tom died
I mean this guy was no couch potato he
actually finished the Boston Marathon
three times okay just a simple selenium
deficiency disease this one's a happy
story evander holyfield two years ago
was banned from boxing because he had
cardiomyopathy heart disease not the
kind that kills you suddenly with a
heart attack but a slow muscular
dystrophy or a wasting of the heart
muscle and they didn't want him to die
suddenly during a boxing match and so we
talked to his cardiologist and his
internist about six months ago and they
gave him some selenium based on our
discussions with them and those of you
who follow boxing know that about a
month ago he was back in the ring and
won his first fight back in the ring
because his electrocardiogram had come
back to normal just by taking some
selenium so there aren't happy stories
if you do something about it
runners are notorious for dropping dead
during exercise Frank Brock here was a
follower of Jim Fixx Jim Fixx died at
age 52 after five cardiomyopathy heart
attacks he was the guy that started the
whole running craze none of you would
have running shoes on if it weren't for
Jim Fixx
and Jim Fixx was a vegetarian didn't
want to supplement with any vitamins and
minerals because he wanted to prove that
it was the running and the exercise in
the jogging that got you lived to be a
hundred and when he died at age 52 after
5 cardiomyopathy heart attacks in the
his last year of life when they did the
autopsy on him his arteries were as
clean as a newborn baby's but they
forgot one technical detail his heart
was very dead
kind of interesting now Frank Brock age
46 died one day before his 47th birthday
and his daughter said she was always the
type of guy who took care of his body
she was such a careful eater we were
embarrassed to eat around him remember
George Foreman hamburgers hamburgers
hamburgers and he's still going strong
and all these tall skinny guys who run
all the time and don't eat meat don't
make it this guy here Tom Dowling from
Kansas City Missouri was a world-famous
marathon runner and he noticed you know
he wore one of these monitors around his
arm and had the little things in his ear
so he could make sure his heart rate was
above 100 all the time for this aerobic
thing and he noticed something after 25
years of running that he had an
irregular heart beat he had a little
heart palpitation so he called up a
cardiologist made an appointment told
what was happening the doc said ok when
you come in plan on being here for a
while because we're gonna do a stress
test you know that's where he had this
electric treadmill and they kind of
raised the level up and and you go to a
maxout and they do an electrocardiogram
during all this and they did this stress
test on him and he died 30 minutes after
the stress test
McClarty mob of the heart attack when
the reporters asked the doctors hey how
come he died in the doctor's office
reporter the doctor said runners recent
deaths nature exercise we know exercise
is good for you even though $100,000
here during exercise it's good for a
because we say so now the X champ
Buster Douglas who lost his heavyweight
championship to I believe it was a
Evander Holyfield two years after he
lost the championship developed diabetes
brittle diabetes and we know that
diabetes has caused adult onset diabetes
is caused by a deficiency of - trace
minerals chromium and vanadium and we'll
talk about that in detail and just a
little note here the rate of brain
cancer in America has gone up 700
percent in the last 50 years and of
course there's all kinds of athletes who
died of brain cancer Lyle Alzado
football player last year I think was
August Fred Lebow the founder of the New
York Marathon died of brain cancer at
age 56 and
in November of 1994 not too many about
eight months ago I guess Wilma Rudolph
the first woman to ever win three gold
medals in track and field died of brain
cancer at age 54 this has nothing to do
with cellular telephones in laboratory
animals we can create brain cancer in
animals by giving them a deficiency of a
trace mineral called gallium GA l li um
gallium you give them plenty of gallium
you sublimate gallium in their feet and
give them a chemical that will cause
brain cancer you can't give them brain
cancer but you give them a gallium
deficient diet and give them the same
chemical they'll all get brain cancer
excuse me so I believe that this
increase in brain cancer in America is
not due to cellular telephones in fact
it is due to a gallium deficiency and
our athletes are giving us the early
clue now here's the bottom line here's
the real clue telling us what's going on
with her a fleece and what their what
they are in fact giving us this early
warning this little study was very
interesting talked about gymnasts in
college and universities as many as 62%
of female college gymnasts suffer from
anorexia they get depressed they don't
eat they're not hungry and if you don't
do something about it they die I used to
see a lot of these little gals up in my
practice because when I practiced up in
Portland Oregon that was a time of Olga
Korbut remember this little gal I think
from Romania and she was the first
gymnast to ever get perfect scores and
all the events that they were in every
parent in in the northwest at least that
I know of
wanted to have their daughters the Olga
Korbut I mean she was the darling of the
world at that point and so I saw a lot
of anorexia way back in those days and
these little gals I used to see dozens
of a month because there was an athlete
core a gymnastic training center and
just about every corner back then and I
did hair analysis on these little gals
and sure enough they were all deficient
very severely deficient in a trace
mineral called a zinc and they wouldn't
eat of course instead of fighting and
arguing with them and sending pills home
to their mothers I knew they were just
gonna flush down the toilet I'd have you
come in and I'd give intravenous
minerals to these girls including
intravenous zinc and ten to 14 days are
back doing their gymnastics they're
eating they're just great little gals
they weren't depressed anymore and the
mothers who took their daughters two
counselors and shrink
those little girls were counseled unto
death many of a remember Karen Carpenter
from the carpenters singing group was 28
30 years old I believe and she had
anorexia and she went all over the world
looking for a shrink or a counselor that
could help her with anorexia nobody gave
her any minerals and they counseled her
unto death now what could possibly be
the common denominator between a
65-pound gymnast a 250-pound boxing
champion seven-foot-tall basketball
players huge football players runners of
all kinds what could possibly be the
common denominator well they all sweat
when they sweat they don't just sweat
out potassium they sweat out all 60
essential minerals and if you sweat out
all of your put selenium you sweat out
all of your selenium and don't replace
it with supplementation your high risk
of dying of a cardiomyopathy heart
disease if you sweat out all of your
copper and don't replace it by
supplementation your high risk of dying
of a ruptured aneurysm you sweat out all
of your chromium and vanadium and don't
replace by supplementation your high
risk of dying of diabetes in sweat alder
gallium and don't replace it you're
gonna get a brain cancer just your
teenage girl you sweat out all of your
zinc you have a 62% risk of getting
anorexia and dying now you don't have to
just sweat when you're an athlete what
if you're a farmer bucking bales every
July in August what if you're a woman
going through menopause and you're
sweating all night what if you're a
baker and ovens are a welder or a steel
maker and you sweat
if you don't replace those minerals by
supplementation your high risk of dying
from those horrible diseases now what
are some of the early warning signs of
mineral deficiencies and of course
that's a question I get asked all the
time farmers know this you've heard of
Hika and cribbing this is where horses
and cows will eat defense rails and
they'll chew on half doors on the barns
and they'll eat the feed box rather than
the feed and so forth innate dirt and
wire nails and rocks shingles off of
roofs and deer bones and all weird
things are not supposed to eat and a
good husband German a good farm or a
good rancher knows those animals are
mentally deficient and they better scoop
some minerals to them otherwise they're
gonna have to rebuild the fence and the
veterinary bills are gonna go up and
they'll lose them from Hardware disease
and all kinds of things
and so we've taken care of that in the
animal industry in human beings is a
little more complex a kids kind of act
like animals they go out in the garden
and eat dirt they see it digging in the
garden you see them eating dirt and they
may eat handfuls of sand in a sandbox
they're telling you they're needing some
minerals many a belief that stuff out of
kitty litter box it's not because it
tastes good but because they're seeking
things to put in their mouths to try and
fill that craving that they have and of
course mom always picks up the kitty
litter box and puts it on the counter
where they prepare food I never figured
that one out yet
and then they smack little Frankie on
the hands that now don't do that dear
this nasty and then Frankie can't get
the kitty litter box anymore so it goes
over and eats lead-containing caulking
from around windows and lead paint
because he's still looking for something
satisfy this need for minerals now
adults are a little more complex because
we're socialized we know if we eat the
wooden legs off of furniture or door
jams or stuff like that they're gonna
come after you with a butterfly net
right Frank is losing it he thinks he's
a beaver he's eating wood and furniture
so we've learned that we can do things
that are socially acceptable if we eat
chips and dips and we become Pepsi
holics and chocoholic sand sugar Alex's
have to have doughnuts every morning and
eat chocolate and candy and so forth I
hear this all the time this is one of
the reasons why America has a weight
problem because we're minerally
deficient people tend to eat chips and
dips and Pepsi's and donuts and
chocolate and things when they really
are craving minerals of course we
already talked about the grey here
another deficiency symptoms early
warning is age spots or liver spots on
your hands that is in fact a selenium
deficiency for people who are taking in
a lot of vegetable oil talk more about
that later if we have time lithium is
one of my favorites minerals because
shrink thinks it's a drug they think
it's a drug but only they can prescribe
is one of those 60 essential minerals
that you need in your diet every day and
like any other essential nutrient if
you're deficient lithium you get
diseases and these include of course
violent behavior manic depression
suicidal behavior you can be a violent
criminal you can be addicted to drugs or
alcohol these are all symptoms of
lithium deficiency and I believe we
should be putting lithium in our
drinking water instead of chlorine and
fluorine because
cheaper than cops and it works you know
to chase down every criminal and spend
your tax money building new jails and
things like that
just put lithium in the drinking water
now you can detect a child who's four
five years old with a lithium deficiency
just by looking at their coloring
projects and church nurseries or
kindergarten or first grade or maybe
looking at the coloring projects that
are put on the walls at Denny's
restaurants and grocery stores during
holidays you notice that here this child
four years old is scribbling all over
the page has no intent of coloring in
the lines and they picked weird colors
okay this child is obviously gonna be a
serial killer later on in life and he's
deficient in lithium and it probably has
pop-tarts and sugar frosted flakes for
breakfast or maybe eight ounces of apple
juice and things like that and all you
have to do is get these kids off of all
sugar natural and process no honey no
molasses no apple juice no grape juice
no pop-tarts no sugar frosted flakes no
syrups no egos and stuff like that and
our tang that's another bad one and give
them lithium chromium and vanadium as a
supplement and don't coach him on
coloring in the lines in three to six
weeks later same kid without coaching
look at the heels on the boots the boots
to glows the tail to glow the border and
the feet in the hand so forth staying in
the lines if you don't take care of
these kids at this point they will be in
trouble they'll drop out of school they
won't learn how to read write and do
math will be a problem for themselves or
families and their communities I used to
see a lot of these kids in my practice
because somehow all the shrinks in
Portland Oregon used to lecture to the
teachers and the teachers when they got
a hyperactive kid or an a DD kid in
their class just for kicks here how many
of you ever seen a hyperactive kid or
have one in your family raise your hand
everybody in this room okay 25 years ago
there weren't any and so all these
shrinks would tell the teachers look if
you get a hyperactive kid or an a DD kid
in your class all you have to do is get
them on ritalin
won't disrupt the class nice to get
parents come to me in tears and say look
if I don't do this they're gonna go to
Social Services and they'll declare me
an unfit parent they'll take the kid
away and they'll put them on Ritalin
anyway so I developed a little test the
judges loved is okay bring your kid in
before breakfast in the morning and
bring the breakfast in and a cooler
don't tell me what it is but don't give
it to him until I tell you to so they
bring a little Frankie in six years old
and say hey Frankie draw me an animal
and this was of course of what animal is
this a giraffe even though it's six year
old you can tell long neck long legs big
spots it's a very good giraffe for a
six-year-old and say okay give Frankie
to breakfast it would be things like Pop
Tarts a tang you know the vitamin C
source or supplement for astronauts
which is 99.9% sugar and yellow food
coloring all the good stuff one or
astronauts are messed up nearing our
sugar frosted flakes and honey and
molasses and all that kind of stuff and
I say okay give him the breakfast I come
back in an hour and a half and I say
okay Frankie draw me a giraffe again
same kid hour and a half after he had a
sugar breakfast looks more like a smooth
birthday candles on his nose doesn't
look like a giraffe anymore this is what
the teacher was saying and this is what
the mother was saying and so all you had
to do is get Frankie on a real American
breakfast I mean oatmeal and eggs and
real orange juice and supplemented with
chromium vanadium and lithium and he
could learn how to read and write and be
a sociable little character and became
number one in the class now if you don't
deal with this and they're four five six
years old you begin to see things like
this this is a geographic tone they get
ulcers on the tongue because they don't
have enough vitamin B zinc and things
like that
the kid is hyperactive has learning
disabilities she's gonna drop out of
school when he gets to be a teenager
he's gonna be experimenting with drugs
and smoking and he'll be a problem for
everybody and himself if you don't deal
with it then when they hit 12 13 14
years old they start looking like this I
want you to go home tonight and look at
your kids eyes and look at their
grandkids eyes these are allergic
shiners this kid wasn't physically
abused this kid has too much sugar in
his diet and no chromium vanadium or
lithium can't learn how to read write
and do math
gonna be a high school dropout gonna be
a real problem for the family and
himself if you don't deal with it then
when they hit 18 to 20 years of age they
look like Johnny here you don't have to
be a clinical psychologist to see that
he's depressed look at the allergic
shiners under his eyes and you read
about kids like this in the newspapers
all the time
he asked grandma for the car keys on her
Friday night like this granny I want to
you know cruise town give me the car
keys I mean when I was 16 I would have
plowed the field without a tractor to
get the car keyed I'd taken the spoon
and done the whole field just to get the
car keys
but today these kids are different he
walks out to the garage gets a baseball
bat comes back in welcome knocks
grandma's head off picks up the car keys
goes cruises town two o'clock morning
comes back it kind of kicks her yeah she
stiffened dead you know so she puts a
gun in his mouth blows his head off
and you read about this in the newspaper
the next morning says teen goes berserk
bludgeoned the grandma to death autopsy
fails to reveal the presence of drugs
that's the key sentence autopsy fails to
reveal the presence of drugs you see
this all the time these are teenagers
who were gorked out on sugar
they've been on Pepsi and ding-dongs his
whole life and has not been supplemented
with chromium vanadium and lithium now
when I grew up on the farm we actually
carried sidearms when you're working in
the field because we had groundhogs and
things like that rooting up the fields
and we had 22s you get a little older
you get a 38 yellow older you got a 357
right and when I got to be about 20 I
carried a 44 Magnum boy I was tough
and I mean them groundhogs didn't have a
chance just the echo would get them
and we carried a 22 and a shotgun things
like that we had these little saddle
sheaths you know on the tractor and we
thought we were big stuff and we had the
poisons we could kill predators and and
pests with we had machetes and
pitchforks and we had machines we could
grind people up with and spread them on
the field and plow them in nobody could
ever find him but we were good Christian
kids we didn't do stuff like that even
though we had all this stuff at our beck
and call we didn't do stuff like that
but today you see things like this in
the newspaper all the time or a 14-year
old boy
Eric Smith from New York clubbed a
little four-year-old to death with a 32
pound rock just to see what death was in
Eric Smith two years before this before
he murdered this little kid was
diagnosed by his personal shrink as
having intermittent explosive disorder
and so his defense attorney tried to get
him off as being innocent by reason of
temporary insanity
now intermittent explosive disorder 50
years ago when I was a kid we used to
call it throwing a tantrum now my dad
could cure intermittent explosive
disorder in about three seconds all he
had to do is start fiddling with his
belt and saying uh-huh
and I was cured of intermittent
explosive bizarre but today because the
average American eats 148 pounds of
sugar every year and some of you are
eating 300 pounds because I don't eat
any which one of you is going to be the
Jeffrey Dahmer I don't know a narrates
because we have this problem you're
seeing more and more and more of this in
the next 10 years the prediction is
we're gonna see a huge epidemic of
violence not from old hardened criminals
but from teenagers this wasn't around 25
years ago attention deficit disorder but
now it's on the cover of Time magazine
because so many families are broken up
one or both of the individuals adults in
the family have attention deficit
disorder that people lose jobs they
become antisocial they become alcoholics
and drug addicts because of their
personal emotional and problems and all
they have to do is get off of sugar no
Pepsi's no ding-dongs no honey no
molasses no apple juice no grape juice
no processed or normal or natural sugar
in any way and get supple minute with
chromium vanadium and lithium now this
little gal here 300 years ago would have
been a vampire or a werewolf she would
have been burned at the stake by her own
fellow villagers or maybe the the head
of the village would have killed her by
driving a stake through her heart as
everybody held her down her name was
Susan Smith she drowned her two sons not
too long ago I got a note in April of
this year and we've learned a lot about
her since she killed those two boys in
high school she tried to kill herself
twice tried to commit suicide twice in
high school she had a lithium deficiency
in high school five years out of high
school she was diagnosed with manic
depression and she was given the wonder
drug Prozac instead of the nutrient
lithium I guarantee you on the night
before she came out drowned those two
boys and killed them she didn't have a
good eight hours of sleep wake up in the
morning and have oatmeal and eggs for
breakfast this gal spent that night
running around from 7-eleven to 7-eleven
maybe went to a few taverns looking for
her boyfriend drinking 32-ounce gulps
and whatnot and she was gorked out that
morning and she drowned those two boys I
mean she was trying to be logical she
says well my boyfriend doesn't like the
kids and so the only way to have my
boyfriend is get rid of the kids
another vampire or werewolf 300 years
ago when at a height was a great farm
life during the day vacuum the rug did
the laundry took care of her kids by
night she drowned she smothered them to
death with a pillow every time they get
6 to 9 months old she smother him to
death with a pillow and in the story she
was diagnosed with depression with him
deficiency she had diabetes which is a
chromium and vanadium deficiency has
gray hair which is a copper deficiency
she has a receding hairline much like a
male pattern baldness which is composed
by a tin deficiency TI m tin deficiency
to all the women writing that down for
their husbands she also doesn't have any
teeth in her mouth which is osteoporosis
doesn't have any calcium magnesium boron
strontium and other minerals she has a
goiter which is an iodine deficiency
she has no less than 8 mineral
deficiencies as no wonder she probably
watched over all day and ate Ding Dongs
and chocolate and things like that and
so you can understand why she was
hearing voices telling her to send her
kids to heaven because it wasn't nice on
earth last one before we get down to the
final stages here and then we'll open up
for personal health challenges this guy
here I would have loved to have seen his
four-year-old coloring projects because
I could have diagnosed him as a serial
killer when he was 4 years old he was
caught eating rogue kills when he was 4
years old sitting on the edge of a state
highway in Indiana when he was 7 he was
thought to be part of a satanic cult
because he was twisting the heads off of
neighbors pets and chickens and birds
and whatnot and tagging him onto their
door jambs and then when he was 13 he
was a full-blown alcoholic he would sit
in the class drink beer and crushed the
beer cans and the teachers were so
terrified of him they wouldn't kick him
out of class because they're afraid he
was gonna burn her house down when he
graduated high school one week after
graduating high school when he was 18 he
killed dismembered and ate his first
human victim he then got into the army
and and became a medic he applied for
medical school and the only reason he
didn't get accepted his grades were very
good because they all gave him a is just
to get him out of there right so the
only reason he didn't get accepted in
medical school when he was under
treatment for alcoholism in the army
they finally kicked him out and he went
up to Milwaukee and lived there for four
years with his grandmother
he worked in a chocolate factory for
four years he took his paychecks and he
bought alcohol and drugs at night I mean
he was a raging alcoholic during the day
he ate for breakfast lunch and supper
chocolate chocolate chocolate cause it
was free working in that Factory and
after four years when the chocolate
didn't satisfy his cravings anymore for
these minerals his Paikea and his
cribbing symptoms
he killed dismembered and consumed 17
human victims
this is Jeffrey Dahmer we could have
picked him out when he was four years
old but they sent him to counselors
instead of giving him some minerals and
getting him off his sugar when his four
years old now just a quick reminder
before we get into the final stages of
this we need 90 essential nutrients we
need 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and fortunately
for human beings over the thousands of
years we've been around we haven't had
to think too much about the vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids because our
food crops been able to take energy from
the Sun use chlorophyll through the
photosynthesis process and manufacture
carbon chains which included vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids and of
course theoretically you can get all the
vitamins and amino acids in fatty acids
you need from your grains and fruits and
vegetables although you have to eat six
cups of 15 different plant foods every
day to get enough vitamins amino acids
and fatty acid over six times fifteen
six cups times fifteen different plants
has 90 cups of fruits and vegetables a
day I mean even if you had the belly
capacity to do that you'd be in the
bathroom run through rolls of Charmin
tissue all day from that much fruit
right now so it is theoretically
possible to get your vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids from grains fruits
and vegetables but not really practical
and of course most people in America the
potato buds out of a Betty Crocker box
and I'm coming here from Idaho you know
about potato buds and they think they're
getting a vegetable so I eat vegetables
I had the potato buzz today then of
course there was Wonder Bread remember
back 50 years ago and I when I was
on the farm we didn't have TV and we had
we didn't even have dryers and went
round and round to entertain ourselves
so a listen to the radio things like mr.
Green Hornet and Captain midnite and
inner sanctum and we'd make jelly
sandwiches listening to these things
with Wonder Bread and I studied that
Wonder Bread wrapper I mean I could tell
you how many blue balloons er was red
yellow and so forth and on the wrapper
it said helps go to body twelve weighs
about ten years later the FDA made him
change it to help build your body eight
ways now if you go into a grocery store
and study the Wonder Bread wrapper just
says Wonder Bread they made him take it
all off of there and you wonder what's
in it
so even though it's theoretically
possible to get all the vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids you need
from your food I still recommend to my
patients to supplement with these things
now you don't take a bag full of dirt
from the Texas oil field and throw it in
the crankcase of your car tracker and
say well they're supposed to be oil in
there but we do that for ourself when it
comes to food and vitamins and minerals
I just find that amazing
now minerals are a different story
plants cannot manufacture minerals and
we need 60 essential minerals every day
to prevent disease and death plants only
have minerals in them based on whatever
minerals are in the soil and that's why
we're in trouble in America because for
the last hundred years and I know I did
on our farm and I'm assuming most people
do on their farm we used a very simple
fertilizer called NPK beacause back then
for 25 bucks an acre it would give us
the maximum yield in terms of tons and
bushels per acre and nobody paid us a
cash incentive or gave us a tax
incentive to make sure we had 60
minerals in the soil and therefore in
our food plants we were taught to grow
tons and bushels and we did a darn good
job at it and that's why we got paid it
only takes five to ten years to deplete
the essential minerals out of our soils
and if youíre eat it goes faster than
that and for a hundred years we've been
using NPK now one of the things I want
you to pick up if you haven't already
done that as a free summary when you
leave tonight is a free summary of US
Senate document 264 US Senate document
264 says there's no more nutritional
minerals left in our farm and range salt
and as a result the crops are grown
there merrily deficient and as a result
of that the animals and people who eat
these mentally deficient crops get
neural deficiency disease and the only
way to prevent and cure them is with
mineral supplements now the scary thing
to me about US Senate document 264 is it
was written and published by the US
Senate in 1936 59 years ago this
information was known did anybody ever
give it to you before no and that's the
time at which in agriculture we started
putting vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds 1936 and
humans unfortunately for us we got
wonder drug
this is when we got penicillin sulfa
drugs and prednisone doctor said we
don't need to know about that nutrition
stuff people get sick we give them some
wonder drugs and cure on US Senate
document 264 now this one here you
should pay attention to this is kind of
an overlay map of the continental United
States and this shows you how much
selenium is in the soil in various eras
or regions of the country the black
areas have absolutely no selenium in it
the dark grey areas probably don't it's
kind of a maybe maybe not so if you eat
food out of your own garden or you go to
a farmers market and get very fresh
fruits and vegetables or grains and
whatnot I still do on it from the field
in Idaho are you getting any selenium no
farmers no they better give selenium to
their sheep and their horses and their
pigs and cows otherwise you get white
muscle disease or stiff lamb disease or
mulberry heart disease why did we do
that for our livestock and we don't take
care of ourselves okay just a quick
detail look at two minerals we'll wind
it up and open it up for questions let's
look at calcium everybody knows about
calcium since tums started talking about
osteoporosis osteoporosis of course is a
tragic disease it's the number 10 killer
of adults the United States is very
costly in terms of human misery in
dollars it cost thirty five thousand
dollars to have each hip replaced if you
get them both replaced there in fact
seventy thousand dollars now farmers
know that we can prevent osteoporosis
and animals we don't have osteoporosis
and animals even because they're even
though we have such a terrible time with
it in humans and here's why farmers are
very practical let's say you have a
hundred head of cows on the pasture and
you didn't have any calves this year
can't repay your operating loan you call
the vet out and say man do I get rid of
this herd of cows it cost me a lot of
money this year feed and labor and
maintain the fence and pasture and I
didn't get any calves what's happening
here so the vet examines the cows to
know there's nothing wrong with the cows
here but your bowl over there has Ostia
Prosis of both his hips had so much pain
couldn't breed the cows that's why it
doesn't have any calves because I'll
tell you what you give me seventy
thousand dollars I'll give that bull to
new hip
next year you'll have some cats so a
farmer being a franchisee to stand over
here dr. boom blows the bull away 28
cents and well the kids are grinding
them up into hamburger and cutting
steaks and roasts off that ol bowl of
the farmer says now doc for $70,000 I
get a new bull every year for 70 years
you know I wouldn't spend that kind of
money but everyone small I get one I'd
like to keep because he throws good
calves any weight and prevent that
osteoporosis thing and the vet says well
sure every time you win one of those
bull calves just give them ten cents a
day worth of calcium in his pellets and
the farmer says you mean I can't prevent
a $70,000 vet bill simply by giving 10
cents a day worth of calcium and the
policy says well yeah he said well I'm
gonna do that because I don't have
insurance for those animals and because
I have to pay for it are my own pocket
I'm gonna do the ten cent a day thing
that's why we don't have osteoporosis
and animals now receding gums is another
one Denis will tell you to floss and
brush after every meal if you want to
avoid our cure receding gums if you
believe that really works I have some
oceanfront property in Idaho to sell you
because it doesn't work I've seen
hundreds of thousands of animals rats
rabbits mice Ram dogs can't sheep
parsa's pigs cows lions and tigers and
bears and they don't floss and they
don't get receding gums
now they do get funky breath
now the reason why we don't get receding
gums and animals is because we've taken
care of the osteoporosis problem
gingivitis receding gums loose teeth
periodontitis pyuria bridges plates all
of these different diseases really are
just osteoporosis of the facial bones
and the jaw bones and that's why we
don't have these problems and animals
because we've taken care of the
osteoporosis problem if you have any of
those dental problems you in fact have
osteoporosis of the face or jaw bones
arthritis now get your pencils out
because I'm going to give you that
complete arthritis formula at this point
for those of you who stage tonight and
been a great audience dr. Wallach Pig
arthritis formula goes like this five
ounces of calcium enriched minute made
orange juice five ounces of calcium
enriched minute made orange juice two
quarter ounce packets of Knox gelatin
unflavored and unsweetened one ounce of
mineral toddy for the colloidal minerals
including colloidal calcium and
magnesium and boron and one ounce of
Total toddy our ultra Body toddy this
will give you the basic dr. Wallach Spig
arthritis formula take that twice a day
faithfully for two months and then call
me in the morning I'll say it one more
time five ounces of calcium enriched
Minute Maid orange juice two quarter
ounce envelopes of Knox gelatin
unflavored and unsweetened one ounce of
mineral toddy and one ounce of either
Tolle toddy or ultra Body toddy which
are vitamins amino acids and minerals
that mixture seven and a half ounces you
want to take twice a day faithfully for
two months before you decide whether
it's actually helping your arthritis or
not hypertension high blood pressure is
not due to too much salt in your diet
it won't help you to take salt out of
your diet what's the first thing and a
good husband German puts out for his
livestock's about that big a salt block
and a dumb ol cow can have all she wants
now doctors think people are dumber than
cows cow can have all the salt she wants
but you can't have any right well we
learned five years ago from a study that
was paid for with your tax money thirty
million dollars they studied high blood
pressure they took ten thousand people
5,000 of which had high blood pressure
they took them off of all salt
medications to see if just a salt-free
diet would help people live longer and
of course they all died very quickly
can't live without salt then they took
5,000 people in a control group they let
them salt their food in fact encouraging
them to salt their food to taste and
then they made them take three times the
RDA of calcium and they don't even know
why they did that they just wanted to do
something different in the control group
have nothing to do with salt and that
control group was supposed to run 20
years to compare with the other group
that are already died out well they had
to stop the control group in six weeks
because 85% of them were cured of their
high blood pressure just simply by
tripling your calcium intake how many of
you got that notice from your doctor
saying it's okay to salt your food to
taste but please please do double or
triple your intake of calcium especially
if you have high blood pressure not a
single person in this room okay insomnia
as we roll around all night wake up in
the morning more tired when you went to
bed that's not a barbiturate deficiency
it's a calcium deficiency
okay your doctor likes to give you
barbiturates kill about 10,000 people a
year but that's okay it's prescription
so they keep track of the numbers for
you they have a new one out called
Halcyon it doesn't kill you but it has
terrible side effects of stomach
cramping nausea vomiting and that's what
they gave George Bush when he went to
Japan now to sleep on Air Force One you
know he's you know he was going to
negotiate with the car trade ambassadors
there from Japan and when I came home I
always turn on CNN news and I turn that
on and here's the Japanese news cancer's
I thought the whole Japanese economy had
collapsed I mean these guys were taking
their ties off and throwing their
jackets on the desk and their hair was
all over the place
sweat flying around and they're saying
things like oh how bizarre amaz
konichiwa woosh
and then I saw that new thing with him
puking all over them guys I mean he
could blame his doctor's prescription
for losing the presidency because that
wasn't very presidential
[Music]
then there's kidney stones bone spurs
heel spurs and calcium deposits doctors
have the malignant dumb belief you have
too much calcium in your diet when you
get those things and they say absolutely
no dairy and for God's sake don't take
any supplements with calcium in it when
in reality you only get calcium kidney
stones bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits when you have a raging
osteoporosis in reality you need more
calcium or magnesium not less a couple
more here cramps and twitches how many
have you ever had a foot cramp raise
your hand be honest just about everybody
in the room has been awakened with a
foot cramp right as the calcium
deficiency your body's screaming at you
give me some calcium darn it then of
course there's twitches eyelid twitches
muscle twitches be honest how many of
you ever had an eyelid twitch raise your
hand yeah just about everybody in the
room now when I was 14 years old my
eyelid is too twitch so loud you could
hear I mean it sounded like and I'd look
in the mirror and say do people see that
is that my imagination and I looked here
enough I could guy caught it one day and
I called my mom hey mom look at this and
she didn't know what it was so he jumped
in the car we drove 80 miles to st.
Louis we went to this lady eye doctor
I'll never forget her name was Mary Jane
Skeffington
and for some reason she had me stripped
down to my jockey underwear I mean she
was an eye doctor
I mean today I get on Oprah with sexual
harassment right the back then it was
just kind of a curiosity and what's her
interest here and I I mean I was 14
years old today right she'd look in my
eyes and kind of shred her shoulder she
go look at another patient you come back
and look at my eyes and after about an
hour that I said don't doc look I play
on the junior varsity football team I'm
the captain of the wrestling team I'm on
the weightlifting team if you have to
amputate my eyelids go for it I mean I
can do whatever is necessary I can't
stand this twitching and cramping in my
eyes and so she knew I was frustrated
she goes her office she comes back with
a little Maybelline mascara eyelash
brush and a little mirror you know
what's all that far she says well your
eyes appear to be normal but you do have
long eyelashes and I think they've hit
your glasses curled banking or tickling
your eyeballs and that's what's
happening I said yeah and she starts
demonstrating he says what I want you to
do is every hour alternate eyes and
start actually retraining your eyelashes
as in oh wait a minute you want me to
sit on the football bench with 25 guys
weighing over 200 pounds and you want me
to start playing with mileage I mean
these guys will sharpen their cleats and
kill me my own team will kill me
so I put on my pants and I go marching
off to the school library and I look at
a health book written by a couple of
nurses and I look in the index under
muscle cramps muscle twitches and sure
enough it says calcium deficiency now
I'm 14 years old the only place I knew
he had calcium was in those calf pellets
in the barn so I ran to the barn and I
had to make this decision was I going to
do this Maybelline mascara eyelash
treatment or was I cannae camp fellas so
I started eating calf fellas
everybody else in school is popping M&Ms
you know now I'm eating a fellas so in
three days time all those cramps and
twitches went away and of course I knew
then the doctors didn't know anything
about Anatomy and probably I don't know
what the connection was between the eyes
and other parts and then they didn't
know anything about nutrition
now PMS premenstrual syndrome the
University of California's 6 years ago
came out and said that 85% of the
physical and emotional stuff of PMS
could in fact be reverse prevented
insured simply by tripling your intake
of calcium over and above the RDA of
calcium so guys if you have a gal in
your family a mother a sister a wife a
daughter or maybe a boss or co-worker
don't give them flowers and chocolate to
try and calm them down give them some
calcium and everybody be happier now low
back pain 85% of all back pain is due to
either osteoporosis of the vertebra
regardless of your age even if you're 10
years old if you have low back pain you
can have osteoporosis of the vertebra or
cramps and spasms and the muscles and so
you want to use dr. Wallach speak
arthritis formula for all of these
things now it's the criminal thing about
this is these are just a top 10 out of
147 different diseases that can be
caused by a calcium deficiency just ten
because we have good insurance and
because we have Medicare and Medicaid
damaged person in America will spend
somewhere between 25,000 and $250,000
during their lifetime and undergo five
to ten surgical procedures for nothing
more than a calcium deficiency any other
industry where you can do something for
ten cents and they charge a $250,000
they get put in jail for fraud but
medicine we just ask the doctor or the
government to tax us so he can pay him I
find that fascinating last one diabetes
number three killers of Americans causes
blindness of all kinds kidney failure
requiring dialysis or maybe kidney
transplant cardiovascular disease of all
kinds of amputations at toes feet and
legs and if you really are determined to
get an amputation make sure you tag the
right leg you know to make sure the
doctor gets the right one and this is
really criminal because every time your
doctor diagnosed is a new die
veticon is his office he drops to his
knees and gives thanks to the Lord and
then when he gets up he runs over and
picks up the telephone calls his
real-estate agent says hey I need a new
apartment complex or a strip mall or a
farm I need to dump two hundred and
fifty thousand five hundred thousand
dollars because I got a new diabetic
patient it's kind of like adding a new
dairy cow to the herd you know how much
money you're gonna get during the life
the useful life of that cow
now 1957 we learned in animals that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with -
trace minerals and alongside onset
diabeetus chromium and vanadium would
prevent and cure it ten years ago 1985
the medical school at the University of
Ann Cooper British Columbia Canada came
out and said the trace mineral vanadium
alone could replace insulin for antal
onset diabetics if you write science
that dog food in Topeka Kansas
manufactured by Hill packing company and
asked them how many minerals are in size
diet dog food they'll proudly writes
bangs they Lotus party in there and they
always include chromium vanadium lithium
and selenium and then you write
checkerboard square st. Louis ralston
purina say hey how many minerals are in
laboratory rat pellets well we put 28 in
there unless the researcher wants more
or less we can do that we always include
chromium vanadium lithium and selenium
and I'll give anybody in this audience a
crisp new hundred dollar bill if you can
find me a human infant formula off the
shelf of a grocery store are a pharmacy
that has more than 12 minerals none of
them contain chromium vanadium or
lithium and only one pro soy be the one
that has 12 has selenium in it none of
the rest do and you might have eleven or
ten or nine minerals in there depending
on which one you choose arbitrarily off
the shelf so our dogs get 40 minerals
our rats get 28 your own kids get 12 or
less is it any wonder our society is
beginning to crumble now if I have
convinced you that being responsible for
taking these 90 essential nutrients is
your responsibility you do have to learn
this last piece of information there are
three types of minerals number one is
metallic these are things like ground-up
rocks
limestone tongues clays dolomite oyster
shell eggshell sea bed minerals of all
kinds feed minerals things
like minerals from the Great Salt Lake
in the ocean stuff like that Celtic
salts these things are only 8 to 12
percent available to little kids when
you're under age 30 young people they
have a pretty good digestive system
we're not designed to eat rocks or
metallic minerals or soil or clay or
dirt when you hit 40 or 50 when you hit
that big for over 50 people dread those
ages because you start getting those
aches and pains and your hair turns gray
and your teeth get loose and your blood
pressure goes up you start getting
diabetes and all these problems that's
because your ability to absorb metallic
minerals drops down to 3 to 5 percent
that's a precipitous drop because you
have a physiology change and about a
year ago a guy jumps up in the back of
the room in the Grand Rapids Michigan
where I was giving a lecture like this
and he says hey doc now I know what I
see in my porta potti business they say
what on earth you seen your porta potti
business he says well every time we
clean those things out and hose them
down and disinfect them to reuse them
again we find hundreds and hundreds of
vitamin pills that come through people
and I said come on now how do you know
they're vitamin pills he's oh that's
easy
they say thier grandmum centrum Centrum
silver and one a day right on the
coating
so next time you're on the pot and you
hear plop plop fizz fizz you know what
it is coming through there and if you
have some gas that day you better jump
off the pot because you don't get
shrapnel in the wrong place
[Laughter]
now a lot of people will say to me look
doc we heard you on the radio we read
your books listen your tapes we heard
your lecturer several times and we've
been taking 2,000 milligrams of calcium
every day for the last 20 years and our
teeth are still loose the arthritis is
still bad
the osteoporosis is getting worse my
blood pressure has gone up and I get
cramps all the time
and I'm taking 2,000 milligrams of
calcium a day what's going on now is
asking what kind of taken and they'll
tell me things like well calcium lactate
I take two of those thousand milligrams
capsules or tablets a day well there's
the problem because out of those
thousand milligram tablets 860
milligrams is lactose or milk sugar only
140 milligrams is metallic calcium and
let's not use these complex numbers to
figure out how much you're gonna get
let's just use 10% easy figuring 10% of
140 is 14 milligrams so if you take two
of those tablets a day you're not
getting 2,000 milligrams of calcium
you're getting 2 times 14 or 28
milligrams of calcium to get 2,000
milligrams of usable calcium from a
metallic tablet you have to in fact take
30 of those with each meal you got to
take 90 Dave gotta take almost a whole
bottle of 100 each day and that's just
dealing with calcium we're not I mean
still have 59 more minerals to go and if
you do that trying to do it I guarantee
you you're gonna develop what we call
BNF disease it's an abbreviation for
belching and farting you sound it sound
like an elephant out in the woods with
bowel problems
[Music]
and you know you have it when your
spouse has to throw a canary in the
bathroom to see if it's safe to go in
there
you know what I'm talking about
[Music]
during the 60s the agricultural industry
came up with chelated minerals because
no farmer is dumb enough to put a dollar
in an animal's mouth and have ninety
ninety cents come out in the manure so
we learned by putting amino acids
proteins and enzymes around the metallic
atom that we could increase the
absorbability to 40 percent it was a
major breakthrough in mineral nutrition
and the health food industry jumped in
there and so if you look at multiple
vitamin mineral tablets today you'll see
a mix of metallic minerals and chelated
minerals but the way that animals and
humans are really designed to absorb
minerals is in the colloidal form
they're ninety-eight percent available
to us two and a half times more
available than chelated ten times more
available than metallic and our food
plants grains fruits vegetables and nuts
are supposed to take the metallic
minerals out of the soil convert them to
colloidal minerals for their own use and
then we eat the food plants and get the
minerals that's how we're designed to do
this we're not designed to eat dirt and
rocks
we're designed to get our minerals from
our food plants however the problem is
US Senate document 264 says since 1936
there's no longer any nutritional
minerals left in us all so even though
the plants have the capability of doing
that they can't do it because the raw
materials are not there in the soil
anymore and this is why we have this
catastrophic disease appearance in
America now what about these people who
live to be 120 140 what is it that they
do what is it that makes them live
healthfully at 120 140 well they do have
a common denominator even though they're
different religions and different races
and cultures and so forth number one
they were all persecuted people's either
they were persecuted for religion
they're persecuted for their politics
and they were chased up into the
mountains as a place to escape of course
and hide and they pick places where you
had to cross a 3,000 foot deep chasm or
you had to go through a little narrow
pass where 100 guys could defend against
ten thousand kind of like the old
Spartans and as a result there's no
utilities up there no heavy industry no
chemical farming and there's no
pollution in the air water and food and
according to the Russians this accounts
for about 10% of their health and
longevity
now the other 90% is more important I
believe and it has to do with just to
throw the dice it's not something that
they consciously did they pick places
that had 60 to 72 minerals in the parent
Rock of the places they live and they
also had to pick places that had
glaciers for year-round sources of water
because they chose places that had less
than two inches of precipitation a year
no rain no snow so they couldn't dry
land farm they had to irrigate and the
water that comes out from underneath
these glaciers is not clear like Perrier
or Evian our bottled water or camp water
our clear well water it looks like milk
it looks like whole milk so they call it
glacial milk and not only did they drink
this stuff and get eight to twelve
percent absorption of these ground up
rocks so when they're you know under age
30 and then three to five percent
absorption these ground up rocks after
age 30
more importantly they irrigated with
this glacial milk for 2,500 to 5,000
years a week after week month after
month during the growing season year
after year generation after generation
for 2,500 to 5,000 years and if you boil
away a quart of that glacial milk you
get two inches of minerals in the bottom
of that quart jar you boil away a quart
of Evian or Perrier water you get as
much mineral as you can put on the head
of a pin and as a result all their food
plants for 2,500 to 5,000 years have
been taking up these metallic minerals
crop after crop and are heavily laden
with these colloidal minerals by eating
these food plants that are rich with
these colloidal minerals these people do
not have diabetes they don't have cancer
they don't have arthritis osteoporosis
high blood pressure then we get
cataracts they don't have any birth
defects they don't have jails full of
violent criminals and drug addicts they
don't have a single clinic hospital or
doctor amongst them they don't have
insurance amongst them they don't have
any taxes simply because they have the
raw materials that it takes to maintain
and take care of their bodies and repair
their bodies now even if I were to pay
your way to go there most people in this
room wouldn't go for any longer than a
week curiosity visit for instance you
might go for it for curiosity to see
what they do and how they live and so
forth and taste the Glacial milk but you
wouldn't live there even if I would pay
your way to do it because they don't
have Kenmore kitchens or cars or air
conditioning or
or electricity they don't have TVs TV
channel changers they don't have sports
teams they don't have anything we'd like
to think about as being American so can
you get these colloidal minerals and
still stay in America and keep all the
things that we love and of course the
answer is yes I'm gonna give you a quick
two-minute commercial here and we can go
ahead and open it up for questions in
number one 1926 a prospector and the
southeast of Utah about 132 miles
southeast of Salt Lake City discovered a
prehistoric Valley that had a very
special deposit and it happened to be a
prehistoric forest that had taken up all
the metallic minerals in the walls and
floor of that Valley in the prehistoric
days and as a result those plants were
rich with colloidal minerals and there
was a volcanic eruption entombed that
forest and was very thin layer of mud
and lava not heavy enough to compress
this into coal or oil
it was very arid in there so it never
petrified or fossilized and as a result
this is very unique stuff and we grind
this up into a flour we soak it in cold
water a filtered spring water from the
nearby mountains and it leeches these
colloidal minerals out of that deposit
after about four weeks you get the
maximum leaching is about 38 grams per
quart and you boil out a quarter of this
stuff it's called mineral toddy has been
on the market since 1926 you get an inch
of these colloidal minerals in the
bottom of that quarter okay and it's
very very interesting stuff contains 72
colloidal minerals 60 of which we know
to be essential now I encourage you to
put it in Minute Maid orange juice
that's calcium enriched because if you
try and drink it straight you know I'm
fine take it straight it'll shrink wrap
your lips over your teeth it's very in
stringent
be honest with you you won't like it if
you take it straight you want to take it
in minute mate oranges as calcium and
rich and also as part of dr. Wallach
Spig arthritis formula and you can
interchange either total toddy or ultra
Body toddy whatsoever available for the
vitamins amino acids plus the minerals
as the other part of dr. Wallach Spig
arthritis formula and ask him out there
at the tables how to become a wholesale
buyer so you get a 30% discount you
don't want to pay retail if you don't
have to you save yourself 30% lastly we
have some books and tapes out there if
you liked what you heard tonight I have
a book it's the best-selling book called
let's play doctor it teaches you how to
use vitamins and minerals and herbs and
alternative therapies for over 400
diseases teaches you how to read medical
lab reports prescriptions records and so
forth so the doctor can't get ahead of
you there and you're gonna save your
life and a lot of money in an
unnecessary misery we have another book
just on mineral deficiencies called rare
earths forbidden cures we also have some
$3 Kant says they're called dead doctors
don't lie appropriately how do you saw
The Tonight Show the other night
okay did you see that did anybody okay
well they had a 97 year old lady on
there who is a handwriting expert she's
one of the people who used the dr.
Wallach speaker arthritis formula I met
her four years ago and when she was 93
and she came in she was kind of like a
wilted rag or daughters brought her in
kind of under the armpits and they kind
of just put her in a chair and she
immediately fell asleep
put her on dr. Wallach Spig arthritis
farm you know three months later I went
back there and gave a lecture and she
walked up the steps holding onto the
rail and tennis shoes and she sat down
ten minutes later she was asleep I went
back there six months later and she's
running up the steps and her tennis
shoes and she has all her girlfriends
within their chattering and giggling and
now she was on The Tonight Show the
other night because she just written a
book she'd been wanting to do it for 40
years and she never had the energy and
so she was on dr. Long's big arthritis
formula I want to thank you all very
much god bless each and every one of you
America
[Applause]
[Music]